the basic concepts on seo google tag
manager google ads social media
marketing facebook ads youtube instagram
and twitter marketing content marketing
email marketing affiliate marketing
marketing hacks digital marketing skills
careers and much more
for this video we have our experts rob
and rahul taking us through all the
topics so without further ado let's
start by talking about digital marketing
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about
first joey learned that digital
marketing was a form of marketing
through which you could advertise to
people digitally digital marketing
leveraged different channels like search
engines websites social media platforms
emails and mobile applications
it would give marketers the opportunity
to interact with and understand their
audience better and to increase the
trust in their brand
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to people based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there are also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with
first joey created content like blogs
videos infographics and case studies so
that he could generate audience interest
in the brand's products or services
this was content marketing
next he needed his audience to actually
see his content the first step was to
create content on specific search
keywords that were relevant to the
target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results
by continuous optimizations joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position
this was seo for search engine
optimization and joey could do all of
this without spending a single penny he
could also drive traffic to the website
with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked he could have text ads that show
up in search engine results image ads
and video ads that show up in websites
and much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing
joey realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
helped them better understand the
products they visited on the website and
assist them in the buying process he
would also send emails to advertise his
products or services to potential
customers that is with email marketing
and finally although joey was able to
grow the brand's funnel he wanted more
traffic from third-party websites this
could be achieved with affiliate
marketing affiliates would promote the
brand or product to their audiences for
a fee with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through
the wait
although joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success
that's when joey realized he had to gain
more knowledge and experience so he
decided to get certified and get ahead
in his career with the help of
simplylearn he took up simplylearn's
digital marketing certification and got
the skills and training he needed to
become an expert digital marketer and
now you know where he is
you too can do the same and grow in your
career by clicking on the top right
corner and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of digital marketing greetings everyone
this is rob sanders and today we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing so thanks for joining us here
at simply learn and let's get started
let's start talking about why digital
marketing is important so let's start
there on the why so we're just a fly on
the wall and we're in an office
environment we're looking at two friends
having a conversation about digital
marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also imagine a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure it's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile
and with digital marketing very
versatile so again going back to our
flyer printing an eight and a half by
eleven okay that's it you know with with
digital marketing running display
banners 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250
300 by 300 i mean the list goes on on
the types of different display sizes not
to mention text ads not to mention video
or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
go to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we could see
real-time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend that
to me is one of the biggest advantages
to digital marketing not only do you get
real-time results but you can control
costs and then obviously optimize based
on the amount of cost you're spending
based on those real-time results with
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience i mean you know i don't
wanna bash traditional marketing too
much i mean if you're gonna put a tv ad
in place you know you're gonna do it on
a tv show that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target
when we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device when we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real-time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the u.s market google tends
has a large market share so you want
your pages on your website to be found
and clicked on organically and so that
means that somebody types in a keyword
you want that relevant page to show up
first on google so somebody can click on
that link okay and we know that millions
of people specifically in the us but
worldwide you search on a daily basis so
if you're ranking for those relevant
keywords you can imagine how much
traffic you can get okay so that's seo
okay and here's an example so you type
in online shopping well you can see the
first listing here is a paid search ad
and we're gonna get to that in a minute
the second organically is amazon okay so
online shopping you think maybe walmart
you think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example
if you want to be found for keyword you
don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay google if
it's google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day it depends on quality score there's
a lot of factors involved and regarding
what you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem's such a popular choice for a
lot of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase the product and if you purchase
it you're going to get 30 off and you
can put the coupon code right in there
with a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchase for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know i would say it's
fairly new i mean if i think about it
we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you can
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you could post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an
infographic or it could be an image okay
there are lots of ways to create content
these days especially in digital
marketing and the great thing about
content marketing is you're writing
content for a targeted audience so
if you're trying to targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically sms or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote
your product or service here's another
example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're gonna talk about first so
we're gonna talk about different stages
of the customer life cycle okay and the
first one is the awareness stage so we
need to get our customers aware of what
we're selling or what we're promoting
okay so the awareness stage is really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
going to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide okay
those are some key questions that people
tend to ask themselves when they look at
a brand okay and when they look at a
product hey do i really need this is it
gonna help me in my life okay and who
who is selling this i mean who is this
brand i mean that's those are just
things that run through people's mind
intuitively that with the right
messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer
talk directly to our targeted audience
through that blog and if we're not
ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on google for example basically we can
be right at the top of the search
results and so somebody can actually see
it when they do a search because we know
millions of people you search on a daily
basis you could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found and so to me this is you
know where the blog comes in seo take
that content get it optimized okay sem
if we're not ranking organically we can
make sure we're at the top of the paid
search results or the the search results
for a particular keyword we want to be
found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you can still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels
there's that consideration stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's gonna be attention grabbing or
something that's gonna get them to
become aware of it that's gonna separate
your posts from all the other posts that
are in somebody's facebook newsfeed okay
so you really have to work hard to
really convince somebody to get their
consideration towards your product or
service so in this stage your customer
considers your product so help them
understand how your product is valuable
okay to me email works really good here
because if you have a targeted audience
this gives you the opportunity to really
answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really get them to take that next
step okay with display you can even do
remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them via display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here okay so you have email
mobile display you know sem these are
all you know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you and now we're on
to the purchase stage so the questions
we want to really make sure we address
here are how are my prices compared to
my competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or trip
advisor or whatever it is you're trying
to sell they're going to be able to see
those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20
and email's a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives pro prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to
not push a product on your customer but
think about how you can complement that
purchases that purchasers or customers
product and then how to improve the
customer buying experience
so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know it's me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throwing an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know
promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you can say hey
look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty
loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10 i'm going to go ahead and
purchase from these guys again so give
those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site you know reward them or if
it's an email and you put a four to a
friend get an extra 10 off it doesn't
hurt because you're incentivizing people
to help you sell your product so with
social display and content use those
banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're gonna write to
give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale a cross sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase date greetings
everyone this is rob sanders from simply
learn happy new year and today we're
going to talk about digital marketing
skills
so digital marketing
allows business owners regardless of the
business non-profit for-profit large or
small
national local international
to really expand their business allows
them to personalize their content they
could save money and most importantly
they can measure the results and so
that's what we're going to focus on
today when we talk about digital
marketing skills focusing on measuring
those results so
suppose anybody wants to work
in marketing or grow
a company or help grow an individual's
company
or ensure to keep up with the
appropriate skills this is what we're
going to cover today so we're going to
cover a few channels
and so let's get right to it
today we're going to start off with
search engine optimization or seo
also known as organic search so seo
is an interesting channel uh it's
probably the premier channel for most
companies
in fact hubspot confirms that 57
of b2b marketers stated that seo
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative
so
it's really important for not only just
generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
seo entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage seo as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it seo is really
divvied up into two pies one pie is
called on page the other pie is called
off page
and so on page consists of things you
can do to the website to help you
be found in organic search so what are
those things well
it could be anything from
you know page load speed to
four or four errors to site maps and so
the point here is if you're going to
manage seo
and you know
that you got to make sure your website's
in tip-top shape or your clients
websites and
good enough shape for google to
recognize it as a legitimate site you
have to have some technical skills
now i'm not saying you have to be
developer but at the same time you have
to know what a 4-4 error is you don't
have to know where and how to generate a
site map and upload that sitemap you
need to know how to edit a robot's text
file so those are you know what i call
soft technical skills but they're all
valid for seo so you have to have some
technical background
staying in the on-page pie
okay
you need to make sure you have not only
skills to write content but skills to
optimize content so you need to be aware
of all the different elements on a page
in order to optimize that page
so again that entails
you know some copywriting skills but
more importantly
and probably more challenging
is to take those copywriting skills and
enhance them for seo okay so making sure
that you're able to understand
what it is that you need to do
to get a page optimized so it can rank
higher
in the search engine results
so those are on page skills
then you got the other piece of the pie
which is off page
so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off-page metrics like
page authority domain authority external
links internal links and so generally
most seo managers have a third party seo
platform that they work with like sem
rush or moz
so it's understanding how to work with
those platforms to measure off page
results so
we always say that seo as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two of those together
you know is is quite a task in order to
rank
and so what brings seo and all digital
marketing channels is understanding
the metrics and understanding
what you're seeing in order to measure
results and improve upon those results
so that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do i measure
the results
and so when we look at seo in terms of
measuring results
on the on page side okay you're gonna
have to do some keyword analysis you're
gonna have to understand
okay what volume is you're gonna
understand how to get the competition
numbers okay and you're gonna have to
understand what keywords to choose okay
so that in itself is a skill being able
to choose keywords based on several
metrics then you're gonna have to be
able to ascertain you know what pages
and what keywords are driving traffic
and how those
pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain authority
or page authority
you have external links internal links
you have no follow and follows and and
you allow these little metrics related
to off page seo so you're going to have
to understand what those metrics mean
and if you can understand what those
metrics mean
and then more importantly act on those
metrics
then that's what's going to help you
improve
your results in terms of seo
so again that's going to be the common
theme here so i'm just going to
highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand
in order to better manage seo as a
channel get on the on page side
you need to understand the
technicalities involved
but
for example
page load what's a good page load time
it's about page load time from a keyword
perspective what's good volume what's
bad volume what's good competition
what's bad competition so if you can
understand
the intricacies of
the measurements related to seo then
that will help you
improve upon this big
channel called organic search so seo
is the practice of getting relevant
traffic to the website okay from organic
search results so it really is essential
to stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking
so that's seo let's transition to search
engine marketing
also known as paid search
sponsored search google ads
bing ads pay per click cost per click
a lot of acronyms a lot of ways to
describe it at the end of the day search
engine marketing
means that hey you as an advertiser have
the ability
and have the opportunity to rank at the
very top of the google search results
now it's different than seo because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're gonna pay google x amount okay
so
unlike seo sem is very fast moving
and so
when we talk about fast moving we mean
that you're collecting a lot of data
very quickly
so sticking with the theme of what
skills should i have for search engine
marketing well
if you're going to collect data then
that means you need to measure the
results of that data
and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to understand
first and foremost what all the
different metrics mean
related to sentry engine marketing okay
so i'm just gonna
rattle off if you will a few of the
metrics but the commonality here is yes
you can learn what those metrics mean
but
you have to act on those metrics
so
one of the the main metrics involved
with search engine marketing is
impressions
so impression is just basically how many
people have seen your ad okay so if your
ad shows up on the search results page
regardless of whether somebody clicks on
it or not
you're gonna get an impression
okay so if you're getting a lot of
impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad
what's a lot of impressions well it's
subjective okay so
it could be a thousand impressions or
ten thousand impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your app
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad and one person who clicked
on your ad then you have a click-through
rate of one percent
now when it comes to google ads and
search engine marketing in general you
want to have a high click-through rate
especially on google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score simply a
number between one and ten that's
assigned to each keyword okay
so what impacts quality score
click-through rate is one of the factors
that impact quality score so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
impressions and very little clicks that
means your click-through rate is going
to be low if your click-through rate is
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low
and
in order to pay less to google you need
to make sure that your quality score is
good so you need to understand the
factors involve a quality score you need
to understand impressions clicks
click-through rate because if you don't
have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about
measuring the results and acting upon
the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you
got the conversion side of the house
so you need to be able to understand
how to get conversions
and
how to maintain a high conversion rate
so for example if you have 100 clicks
and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion
okay
and if that number is high like say 20
dollars and you're only selling a
product that's say ten dollars
well then you got a problem
and so there's a lot of different
metrics involved with search engine
marketing you're collecting this data
very quickly so you need to be able to
react to the data that you see
so that's the skill set really involves
search engine marketing if you're
getting the data
if it's a low click-through rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or
very low impressions you need to be able
to understand
how to react to what you're seeing and
what your data you're collecting
that to me is the primary skill bottom
line with search engine marketing and
there are other skill sets involved
don't get me wrong i mean it's nice to
be able to write copy
because with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so
writing copy
being able to understand your target
audience
those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results okay let's switch
over to a traditional marketing channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites you know listen we're all
bombarded with emails
uh
and you know what
it it becomes cumbersome at times i mean
it's easy to just disregard an email
and so to me the key here if you're
going to do email marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope
that that email is relevant to that
audience okay so you need to be able to
really identify
who it is we're sending this email to
and
a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper hill to climb if you will
but really email marketing is it
involves
emails that promote the brands products
and services
and if you could target the right
audience or making sure you have the
right audience
then you got a good chance of having
successful email marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails you know
it's like having a blank canvas you can
be as creative as you want as long as
you're talking to the audience so
the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copywriting saying the right things but
not saying too much
the same time making the email
aesthetically pleasing as possible so
that when somebody does open the email
they're going to be able to react to it
so you know writing copy with strong
call to action or really relevant copy
that really talks to the audience i mean
those are all keys for email marketing
in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's
a b testing
and so a b testing is simply taking an
original
and creating a variant and testing the
two to see which one performs
well you could certainly do av testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if i'm going to send an email to 100
people
i'm going to send 50
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject client and why is this important
because i want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if i see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or
the original subject line then i know
that this subject line works
and therefore i'm going to apply this
subject line moving forward and then
what am i going to do i'm going to take
it and test it against another variant
so you should always do a b testing on
subject lines so the concept of a b
testing should not be lost on any
digital marketer okay whether that be
seo search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of a b testing
and of course going back to measuring
results with email you have a different
set of metrics
we already mentioned open rates so if
you send out
100 emails
how many people open the email okay you
want that open rate to be as high as
possible
and then when they open the email
the people click on that cta or any of
those links in the email okay so you
want a high click-through rate
and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
gonna go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so what's the engagement
rate
of the landing page from the email
okay so
it's really important that you have an
understanding of all the different
metrics involved with email marketing
and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate
could it be the subject line isn't that
good possibly that's why you have to do
testing if you're getting a low click
they're right on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you gotta look at that and figure out
how to improve that
okay so you can apply a b testing the
landing page so there are always ways to
react to the data regardless of what
campaign or regardless of what digital
marketing channel you're working in
so that's the commonality here
one point on email marketing is if
you're going to measure the results of
the campaign whether you're using
you know vertical response or mailchimp
or
you know some other email marketing
platform you want to make sure you have
what we call a utm tracking and if
you're using google analytics having utm
tracking or understanding what utm
tracking is allows you to measure the
results of that email marketing campaign
in google analytics so that's another
skill set you should have being able to
apply
your tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email okay because
if you don't it's going to be hard to
measure the results in google analytics
so let's focus on one more marketing
channel here and that's social media so
we all know social media isn't going
anywhere it's becoming more and more
popular
in fact your offshoot of social media is
really influencer marketing
uh you know if somebody an influencer
has millions of likes on say tick tock
or instagram
you might want to engage with that
influencer
and help you promote your brand or your
product
isn't that really what social media is
it's a platform whether that be you know
facebook or or twitter
it's a it's a platform to help you
promote
your brand your product your services
and it's a chance for you to
get to message
your user base your community
prospective clients
people who
don't even know about your brand it's a
chance to build awareness so social
media
holds a lot of different
uh strategies if you will in fact
nearly almost 4 billion of the world's
population uses social media
let me see there's seven something
billion people in the world well
that's a large percentage the majority
of the percentage of the world uses a
social media platform okay
in fact
just like seo when you need an seo
platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later
there's sprout social there's hootsuite
there's buffer in fact buffer confirmed
that 73 of marketers believe social
media marketing has been
somewhat effective or very effective for
their business and that's promising
because social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while
it can be a very fickle channel meaning
if you're trying to promote a product or
service on facebook
and it's very
very going to be very hard to pull that
person away who's engaged
with their facebook feed
not only just to get them away from the
facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone converting so that's
why when i say very fickle but you know
it's somewhat encouraging if buffer's
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing
can be effective and it can be effective
you just have to have the right strategy
so to me
one of the skill sets you should have if
you're going to be a social media
marketing manager is being able to
understand
you know what is the strategy here what
are we trying to achieve
when
we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay
and so
that's really the first thing it's
really understanding
what platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then
what channels or social media platforms
if you will work best for us is that
twitter is that facebook so it's being
able to kind of formulate a strategy a
plan if you will for social media
marketing because the last thing you
want to do as a marketer is endlessly
just post content for the sake of just
posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have metrics
and social media is not shy on the
metric front okay so you have reach
you have impressions you have engagement
rate in fact every social media channel
has its own set of specific metrics
whether that be likes followers shares
uh
reviews stars if you will
so it really depends on the social media
platform that you're using
but at the end of the day
you need to be able to measure the
results if you're posting
let's just say on facebook
and your whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post or act on that post then
you need to be able to measure the
engagement how many people saw the post
how many people engaged with the post
okay
and so just like any other marketing
channel you're collecting data and you
need to react to that data but more
importantly
it's about being able to
you know put a strategy together first
and then i would you know a skill set i
would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know i just named buffer or hootsuite or
sprout social they're all good in their
own right but they're all going to have
different features so to me
understanding what social media platform
works best for you you want to choose a
social media platform that you know
allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are
you know reacting to in terms of
hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform
okay so you want a listening tool if you
will
uh as part of that social media platform
so it's understanding what platform you
want to use when it comes to social
media marketing it's understanding what
strategy
that that platform is going to help you
when they enact okay and then it's also
that social media platform that's going
to help you understand
the data so you can react to the data
so
those are all to me the skill sets you
need as a social media manager
and then
an offshoot of social media
is paid social
so just like search engine marketing
you can advertise on say twitter
linkedin facebook
on a cost per click basis meaning if
you're showing your ad on linkedin and
somebody clicks on it you're gonna pay
for that click you're going to pay
linkedin or you're going to pay twitter
you're going to play facebook so it's
understanding
you know the skill sets involved with
paid social is understanding what assets
you can have when advertising on these
platforms you know can you use video on
linkedin or facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and
you know how big do those images need to
be and can you have wording on those
images or what are the guidelines
involved with having images as part of
your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media
and of course when you do advertise
again a whole nother set of metrics
you know how many people saw your at how
many people clicked on your ad how many
people engaged with the landing page how
many people converted what was the cost
per conversion so all of those are
metrics that we covered in search engine
marketing they apply with paid social so
you have the opportunity on paid social
you have the opportunity on social media
to really get your message out there
it's really understanding
what kind of data you're collecting what
are the results of the ad or the post
and how do you react to that and that's
really the common theme with digital
marketing skills
if you're not a big fan of numbers
you're not a big fan of excel if you
will or spreadsheets
if looking at a mountain of data scares
you
well
then you might want to think otherwise
when going into digital marketing but if
you want to embrace the data
then digital marketing is really a great
career because
if you can get the data and you know how
to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run
right that should do it for today thanks
for joining look forward to reaching out
to you uh for more
of these uh webinars uh feel free to
email us or go check out our website at
simplylearn.com
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
[Music]
before we get on to talking about mobile
marketing let's have a look at some
stats related to mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
revenue in leading b2b organizations so
what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember sms's that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience through multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails sms
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customer and personalized
marketing
in mobile marketing the primary focus is
on the customer want them to increase
brand loyalty give customers special
offers or show them personalized ads
based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying trends with
data by leveraging data different trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an a b test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what doesn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
aso advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine crm or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also crm marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage crm
software see sales increased by 29
sales productivity increased by 34
percent and sales forecast accuracy
increased by 42
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what crm is all about
crm is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crms mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in crm
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns
now although what metric you focus on
entirely depends on your requirements
here are some of the commonly used
metrics
there's customer churn which is
basically customer attrition there's nps
which is a measure of how satisfied your
customers are best customer retention
cost and first contact resolution rate
which is a percentage of customer
support tickets that get resolved at the
first shot
next understanding how different crm
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms there's
salesforce hubspot crm zoho crm
microsoft dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simplylearn dynamics 365 by
microsoft and finally hubspot academy
sales professional credential by hubspot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers say visual images are the most
important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies in western content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good you might wonder what does
designing have to do with digital
marketing plenty actually if you have an
understanding of designing yourself in
the scenario where graphic designers are
unable to bring your idea to life you
could do it yourself desiring for
yourself what the content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creative for the ad
next let's have a look at key concepts
of designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden point rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like adobe photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by coursera introduction to
graphic design by linkedin and
fundamentals of graphic design again by
coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
where does most of your audience come
from which platform is better suited for
your content those are the questions
that need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like hubspot and
hootsuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like pr
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of b2b
marketers outsource their demanding copy
needs
next it also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more site traffic and
produces brand recall which brings
higher engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
persuades individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website buy a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting
first understanding the customers and
the competition so from the customers
several bits of vital information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of engagement what
kind they dislike and much more
likewise from the competition you can
find out what kind of writing they have
success with what they are doing better
from your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
let's have a look at some certifications
now
here we have the creative copywriter
academy then we have the idm award in
digital copywriting by the institute of
data and marketing
and finally we have american writers and
artists copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 global
email users amounted to 3.9 million by
2023 this is set to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81
smbs rely on email as their primary
customer accusation channel and 80 for
retention
next again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience
in a way email marketing could nurture
the relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at key concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation
emails can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them and each of them can
impact your customer base in a different
manner depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like hubspot
and mailchimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like hubspot
academy email marketing by hubspot then
email and affiliate marketing mastermind
by uteny and finally advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached midway i
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat i'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to simply learn's channel to
stay up to date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number 4 social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 percent
of the world's population uses social
media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of millennials 77.5
percent of generation x and 48.2 percent
of baby boomers are active social media
users
so now let's have a look at social media
marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages
so it's important to have experience
with them so that the one that best
suits your requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on youtube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more
then we have analytics experience with
social media marketing tools like buffer
and buzzsumo can help organizations by
providing alerts based on keywords brand
names links domain and much more
among other things it also tracks
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simplylearn
then we have social media marketing on
linkedin learning and finally hootsuite
social marketing certification by
hootsuite
and now for the top three number three
pay-per-click of ppc first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38
ctr on google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in google ads
now let's talk about ppc
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform ppc
for ppc most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine result page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of ppc
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works
each of them have their own but somewhat
similar rules prices restrictions and so
on
then we have google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative players among the
search engines google ads provides
marketers with a sizable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how google ads works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it i'll
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
cpc or course per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as i mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have google ads certifications by
google then advanced pay per click ppc
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have microsoft and
excellence program by microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60
of all the clicks
and according to google where to buy
plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to hubspot 57
percent of b2b marketers stated that seo
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or a ceo
refers to the method adopted by an
organization to grow the quality and
quantity of website traffic by making it
more visible to the users of a
particular web search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results seo improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of seo
technical seo the technical side of seo
like server side settings site maps
server response code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines this by extension helps generate
traffic and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both seo and content marketing can
not exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and seo provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
the process of search engine
optimization can only be successful if
there's a combination of both external
link building and internal link
optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability seo must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like moz and google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have google analytics and
google webmaster
google analytics will help with tracking
and reporting website traffic google
webmaster will help track your website's
search performance with the help of
google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have seo training course by mers
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have hubspot seo training course
provided by hubspot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like apache spark
tableau and sas can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have google analytics google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website it
records activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component
understanding data visualization would
help with understanding data in a quick
and clean manner
it enables brands to identify emergent
trends and to respond to it quickly
with it the brand story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrative with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by
coursera then we have data analyst
masters program by simply learn and
finally we have micromasters program and
marketing analytics by edx today i'm
going to tell you how you can become a
digital marketer so first off let's
answer the most important question who
is a digital marketer now a digital
marketer is responsible for several
things let's go through some of them
first off they're responsible to develop
as well as manage marketing campaigns to
ensure that the goals of the
organization are fulfilled they need to
create a marketing strategy which is
based on analyzing their competition as
well as the benchmarks within the
industry they need to drive website
traffic as well as acquire leads which
are then worked upon by the organization
or the business they need to utilize web
analytics tools so that they can measure
and optimize the campaign which is
basically figuring out how well the
campaign is doing and if it's not doing
well how they can make it better and
finally they need to be able to enhance
brand awareness which is just letting
people know that the brand exists and
how the brand can make their lives
better next up let's talk about how to
become a digital marketer to become a
digital marketer you need a certain set
of skills skills like search engine
optimization search engine marketing or
sem email marketing social media
marketing affiliate marketing content
marketing and finally mobile marketing
so the first step you need to take to
become a digital marketer is to learn
seo so seo or search engine optimization
is the process of increasing the quality
of your organic traffic which is nothing
but the traffic that comes to your
website without having seen any paid
advertisements just because your website
is one of the first few results when
they search a particular query on a
search engine seo involves on-page seo
as well as off-page seo so how to do
on-page seo first off you need to do
keyword research keyword research is one
of the most important steps when it
comes to seo it is the process of
identifying popular words and phrases
used on search engines by users you need
to be able to identify keywords with
high search volume high relevancy and
low competition next up we have
technical audit so search engines around
the world have internet bots performing
a particular process known as crawling
in this process these search engine
internet bots these search engine bots
also known as spiders scan a website and
copy the entire website's content and
store it within the search engine for it
to index now you need to ensure your
site is being crawled and indexed next
you have onsite optimization you need to
develop high quality content meta tags
url and sitemaps and finally user
experience you need to provide good
website architecture as well as internal
linking structure next up let's talk
about how to do off-page seo this is
made possible with the help of link
building this is the process of
navigating links from other websites to
your own and by building external links
to your website your organic search
ranking can be improved now let's talk
about some seo tools you have moz google
keyword planner semrush and ahrefs now
let's talk about the next step required
to become a digital marketer which is to
learn sem or search engine marketing
search engine marketing is a practice of
marketing a business using paid
advertisements on search engines and
other websites so basically this is a
way of attracting users towards your
website or a particular product that
you're offering so how can you do sem or
search engine marketing first off you
need to determine your goal and define a
budget you need to ensure that you have
a goal in mind for example do you want
more leads do you want to increase
traffic or improve brand awareness and
much more after you're done with that
you need to define a budget how much
money are you ready to spend to achieve
this goal then you need to choose a list
of relevant keywords which is keywords
on which you'll be bidding to advertise
you need to finalize your keywords and
then bid on them which is basically are
you ready to pay for how many clicks
you're getting or for acquiring
customers or making them leads and so on
you need to create a compelling headline
for your ad campaign you need to monitor
the performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
target your audience with remarketing
campaigns for example if a customer does
not go through with the conversion
process they can be added to the
remarketing audience so that they can be
advertised to again some of the popular
sem tools are google adwords editor fb
ads manager bing ads and adroll now for
the next step to become a digital
marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is a
really efficient as well as inexpensive
way to generate high return on
investment it can be used to convert
prospects into customers by sending
personalized emails to a targeted
audience so how do you perform email
marketing first off you need to discover
your target audience and create segments
in which you can divide them depending
on their behavior you need to select and
create your type of campaign depending
on the goals you want to achieve you
need to select a suitable design for
your campaign you need to have a
compelling subject line and email
content which is very important when it
comes to email marketing you need to
send campaigns immediately or schedule
an email and finally you need to measure
results such as open rate click-through
rate response rate and so on you also
need to perform a b testing to find out
what works and what doesn't some of the
popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot marketo send in blue
and so on and now for the next step you
need to learn social media marketing
social media marketing involves the
promotion of your product and services
on different social media platforms
using different types of content now
this could be just sponsored posts video
advertisements images articles and so on
now how can you do social media
marketing first off you need to choose a
suitable social media platform for your
business it could be facebook youtube
twitter linkedin and so on next up you
need to find your target audience now
each of these platforms has a particular
niche that occupies it now for example
facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy pinterest is usually
used by females linkedin can be used for
employee networking and youtube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on youtube you need
to create as well as curate engaging
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
then you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have hootsuite
tweet deck buffer sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now a merchant is
an individual who pays a commission to
the affiliate who could be a third party
site or entity to drive sales bring
leads or new customers with the help of
referrals now how can you do affiliate
marketing first off you need to choose a
tool through which you can find
affiliates who can advertise your
product now you need to choose affiliate
on the basis of how much traffic the
affiliate website gets how successful
the affiliate's previous campaigns were
and and how much commission the
affiliate asks for then you need to
specify the format that the affiliate
must use when they're advertising your
product or service you need to keep a
record of the customers who purchased
your product or service through the
affiliate and finally pay the affiliate
based on the commission rates now let's
talk about some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools there's cj affiliate
volume has offers and even now for the
next step to becoming a digital marketer
you need to learn mobile marketing now
mobile marketing enables the business to
communicate with the targeted audience
through any mobile device this is
through sms emails mms's and so on so
how do you do mobile marketing first off
you need to create a mobile buyer
persona which is you know what kind of
person is using the phone you need to
set business goals like what goals
basically determining what goals you
want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slick text localities
admob facebook mobile ads and much more
now for your next step in becoming a
digital marketer you need to learn
content marketing content marketing is a
bull marketing technique of creating as
well as sharing valuable content now
this could be blogs videos or articles
which solves the problem of the target
audience this holds their attention by
adding value to their lives and can end
up converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to define your target
audience then you need to determine what
kind of content you are creating it
could be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a content
management system using a content
management system such as the hubspot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools there's
linkedin pulse paper.li flipboard
traffic and many many more now let's
talk about some additional resources now
there are a huge number of videos online
about digital marketing and i recommend
you go through some of them so that you
have a basic idea about their
fundamentals now this is where simply
learn's youtube channel can help you you
can take advantage of simply learn's
digital marketing tutorials you can go
to this playlist right here and here you
have tutorials on what is seo how you
can rank number one on google keywords
research facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your youtube videos facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing google tag manager google
analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the united states the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately 65 000 per year similarly
the average salary for a digital
marketer in india is approximately 5
lakh rupees per year now let's talk
about how you can become a certified
digital marketer now there are a number
of different certifications available
for you there's the google ads
fundamental certification the facebook
certified planning professional
certification the hubspot content
marketing certification the hootsuite
social marketing certification and
simply learns digital marketing
specialist masters program now here's
another way simple learn can help you
simply learn has a number of different
digital marketing certification has a
number of different digital marketing
certifications let's talk about the
digital marketing specialist masters
program in this program there are a
number of different certifications such
as the digital marketing certified
associate advanced web analytics
advanced seo and so on the certification
also provides the omcp certification
exam voucher worth 395 dollars upon the
completion of the masters program it has
45 plus projects and can help you get a
salary of close to 17 lakhs per annum it
is also accredited by hootsuite facebook
the omcp and so on so now let's have a
closer look at the digital marketing
course or the digital marketing
certified associate certification
training now this certification provides
53 hours of instructor-led training 40
plus hours of self-paced videos
instructor-led online project mentoring
sessions helping you prep for
examinations from the omca google ads
and so on it has industry accreditations
from hootsuite facebook and the omcp and
it covers more than 35 tools such as
facebook insights youtube analytics
crazy egg google keyword planner google
ad manager linkedin ads buffer semrush
and so on so why don't you go on to
simplylearn.com so that you can get
started on your journey getting
certified and getting ahead hey guys
welcome to this video on digital
marketing career jobs resume salary
skills roles and responsibilities
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to health care our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved our lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on digital marketing has the
following types
search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine marketing
affiliate marketing
native advertising
marketing automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course so now
let's talk about everything related to a
digital marketer
but before we can get started let's go
to a more familiar setting on where a
digital marketer belongs and strives
the office now let's start by talking
about
who is a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is use digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for
developing and managing marketing
campaigns this means that the success of
the entire marketing efforts of a brand
or an organization entirely depends on
how competently a digital marketer
develops the marketing campaign
the work doesn't end there though the
digital marketer also needs to manage
the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer
hootsuite and sprout social to measure
and optimize marketing campaigns based
on data obtained from the tools
and finally they're responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing
there's search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine optimization affiliate
marketing and email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with seo you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of seo has two parts
on page and off page seo let's have a
look at each of them in detail first
let's have a look at on-page seo
on-page or on-site seo is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or html code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query
on-page seo is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page seo off-page or
off-site seo refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine result pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
off-page seo can also be performed with
the help of link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
some of the popular seo tools are moz
google keyword planner
and ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions
increased leads
that's what you need to decide here then
you need to set up buyer personas
a buyer persona is a profile created
based on research that represents the
target customer that might enjoy your
products or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a content
management system of your choosing
there are a number of options available
like wordpress mailchimp and squarespace
you will need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that will attract
the attention of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you'll need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools
there's buffer basumo follower wonk and
hootsuite let's now talk about
the next type of digital marketing that
is social media marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build your brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you will need to listen to and engage
with followers analyze results and run
social media advertisements the process
of social media marketing involves
like before you first need to determine
what goal you want to achieve
you need to determine whether you need
increased conversions
email signups lead generation or any
other marketing goal
at this stage you need to determine what
your audience enjoys the most
you need to find out which files get the
most amount of engagement likes or
shares
then you'll need to research about your
competition within your niche
see what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from their audience and how
you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice
like linkedin facebook instagram twitter
or youtube and start creating marketing
strategies on how to make the most out
of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same
you will then need to create a social
media calendar
these are spreadsheets or applications
that will enable you to plan your social
media posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
and finally you will need to keep
testing evaluating and making
adjustments to your marketing campaigns
to finally reach the sweet spot where
you have a perfect social media
marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is hootsuite
tweetdeck sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign
mode leads conversions
subscriptions
you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against larger ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning you will then need to decide
on what keywords you want to advertise
and then start bidding on them to ensure
that a user sees your ad when they
search for that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments
and finally you will need to make sure
you make regular optimizations and
adjustments based on the data you've
collected and re-target potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are google ads
facebook ads manager
ad role and binge ads just to name a few
next up let's take a look at affiliate
marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a merchant's products
the affiliate usually promotes the
product and earns a commission for each
sale they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations
email sign ups conversions and
subscriptions here's the process of
affiliate marketing first you will need
to decide the affiliate network you want
to choose
the affiliate network is like a favor
for both merchants and affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
as a merchant you will need to set up
specific rules
guidelines image specifications
commission costs and other details that
an affiliate needs to accept before they
can apply to advertise for you
after this affiliates apply to advertise
on the merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate
and finally the affiliate is given his
or her commission and likewise the
process repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools
we have cj affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign
then you decide what kind of emails you
want to send is it a welcome email a
newsletter a lead nurturing email a
re-engagement email that's what you've
got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing
these tools can help you with templates
for emails create email lists track
performance and do much more
you will then need to attract users with
a reason to subscribe to your emails
with attractive opt-in advantages like
exclusive access to sales discounts and
so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that'll
attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design
and finally you will need to perform a
or b tests and use analytics to measure
how well your campaign is doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
some popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot sendinblue and marketo
just to name a few
now let's take a look at some digital
marketer carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of glassdoor
first we have digital marketing manager
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately seventy five thousand
dollars per annum in the us
in india he or she can earn
approximately seven lakh rupees per
annum
next we have seo manager in the united
states an seo manager earns
approximately 62 000
per annum
whereas in india an seo manager earns
approximately 5 lakhs per annum
then we have search engine marketing or
ppc expert a ppc expert in the us earns
approximately 74 000 dollars per annum
whereas in india a ppc expert can earn
approximately 4 lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the us a social media manager earns
approximately fifty thousand dollars per
annum in india he or she can earn
approximately five lakhs per annum and
finally we have the content marketing
manager a content marketing manager can
earn approximately 65 000
in the united states
in india he or she can earn
approximately 5 lakh rupees per annum
let's have a look at a sample digital
marketer resume
first off you start off with the usuals
like name address and the other stuff
following this you will need to add a
brief summary of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experience with
in this case this person has two years
of experience in just about every
important type of digital marketing your
summary can vary based on the job role
you're looking for
you give them links to your socials and
then add experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for
for example for the role of a sem expert
having experience with google ads and
google analytics is mandatory so that
has to be a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed
having completed the right courses can
have a significant impact on your higher
ability today we're going to talk about
digital marketing tools so fasten your
seat belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019
but ones that have performed well in the
past that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future so past present and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this with a good focus on a lot
of different marketing channels here so
we're going to focus first on seo talk
about some of the tools related to
on-page and off page we're going to
switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so be good to kind of
see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization
or organic search we have a mixture of
paid and free so there's a lot of
different platforms but if you're
focusing on seo you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume
and low competition okay we wouldn't
want to find non-relevant keywords with
high competition low volume that
wouldn't make sense so we need a tool to
kind of help us put it all together and
so the tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here mail delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another key to it if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46
and at the top of the page high range
16.61
so
that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive
then it's probably going to take me a
bit longer to be found for this keyword
on page one of google so that's the
whole idea behind google's keyword
planner and note that you could change
some of the settings here so if you want
to choose a different language okay you
can hone in on a longer or shorter
period of time you can even choose a
specific location so i chose taxes i can
certainly choose the entire united
states to get a sense of what the volume
would be for the total u.s so you have
settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively i can
certainly use another tool
to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask moz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from
eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between one and one 100 and
so i could see this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's if it's a hundred it's
very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword
you know they also give you some good
keyword suggestions so moz is a good
alternative tool and we'll be coming
back to moz related to seo for some
other of its features but for now if you
don't want to necessarily use google's
keyword planner because maybe you're not
running google ads you can always use
mazda remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you could test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use mods we want to be able to
use google's keyword planner not only to
search for all
those relevant keywords available to you
but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume and low
difficulty low competition we also want
to select primary and second keywords
wisely so remember when you optimize
you're optimizing a page for more than
one keyword so you want to be able to
have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so moz gives you that
information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic
hrefs again moz let's take a look at
google search console and i want to hone
in on google search console because it
is free and it's a must if you're going
to work on seo you need to be working in
google search console and so the whole
key behind google search console is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified when
school can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here i'm looking at a
website and what am i looking at i'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these pages back to their server
they're letting us know
if we actually have any issues so here i
can see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue
a 404
you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i could
see submitted url marked new index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you know fall victim to this error
and so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
so these are the errors i can see they
certainly were able to crawl and index
9115 pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54 000 plus pages and
then we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they've discovered via the
sitemap and so
the whole point of a sitemap is we want
to be able to get and push the urls to
google not have google come to our site
and discover them this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with google all the urls that you have
on your site that you want google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report okay so google is a staunch
believer in mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand
how your site fares via mobile and when
i say fares via mobile is it mobile
friendly is it responsive is it loading
quick enough you know is it formatted to
google standards and so if there are any
issues google is going to let you know
what those issues are so here i could
see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read
click elements too close together the
viewport not set to device width and
then content wider than the screen so
there's 10 pages that fit under this
error and if i actually click on it the
error i can see what those 10 pages are
and so when we're done we can actually
when we address the issues we can
actually have google validate whether
the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with google
telling google look i see what the
issues are i'm gonna fix them and then i
want you to validate them okay so this
is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
google's attention google's going to
validate them and get these pages
indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search console shows us
what pages have the most links okay so
here we can see the home page has 26 000
plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i could see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so
externally i want links from other
websites pointing to various pages on my
site and i certainly want my pages
linking to one another on my site and so
i'll be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using google
search consoles links report okay
there's one more report that i think's
of interest in google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with google
analytics so you can see the same report
and analytics if you're able to link up
google search console with analytics and
you should be able to do that all you
need to do is make sure you use the same
email address that you use for analytics
and search console so it needs to be the
same email address you could certainly
link up the two and have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
google so when they're typing them into
google we can actually see
how many impressions
the keyword queries received and how
many clicks the keyword queries received
and then i can see click-through rate
and average position okay so here i can
see
for this particular keyword on the first
line i could see over the course of the
last three months it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the
209 000 297
into the 120 000 397 okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so we could see a
little bit more than that too we can go
from queries to pages we can go from
pages to countries so we get a sense of
how many impressions and clicks i'm
receiving by country and importantly we
can see by device so here i can see a
majority of the people who conduct a
search related to my website primarily
do it on desktop now i mentioned the
beauty of the google search console
performance report is that you can link
it up to google analytics and when you
do that all you need to do then is go to
acquisition google search console and
then from there you can choose landing
pages countries devices or queries so i
could see the same data that i see in
search console but this time i'm looking
at it in google analytics and so here i
can see what my search queries are my
clicks my impressions my click-to-rate
bike search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on-page
optimization but
for off-page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 and 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that doesn't have a good domain
authority and the site appears a bit
scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here i was like this particular
site because it has so many links
pointing to me or it has at least one
link pointing to me that i probably want
to disavow myself because it's probably
hurting my own domain authority so
that's the great thing about this
linking domains report is i'm able to
hone in on not only who's link linking
to me meaning domain but how many
linking domains does that domain have
what's the spam score of that domain
what's the domain authority of that
domain and then i can get into a little
bit more detail and actually see you
know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority spam etc
everything you need to use in order to
measure off-page seo so that's the great
thing about moz is they have not only
on-page seo tools but off-page seo tools
and moz is a freemium so to speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo-tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here
you like some of these tools you can
start your free 30-day trial so i use
and lean on moz a lot for all that it
has to offer from choosing keywords to
rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos
and check them out and that should kind
of complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner
moz and google search console okay let's
switch over to email marketing tools and
so with email marketing tools we have a
lot available to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available
you know marcato is a good tool you know
marcato is a good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma
you know feel free to to note that in
the comments section below this video
i'm curious as to how many people
actually use you know different tools
because there are so literally so many
email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a daily basis
so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you could certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around
that particular audience so you know you
have a good tool when you can do that
when you can really segment for your
audience okay you want to be able to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time and day so these tools also allow
you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly
design the email so if we click design
email again this is important because
with email marketing you want to be able
to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer
so
you know here you can see there's some
lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so here i could see
this email that was sent out in june i
could see it was sent to 95 000 plus
subscribers okay of the subscribers i
saw 2 000 plus open it and 157 clicks so
i can view this report in more detail
just by clicking on view report so again
we want an email platform that's going
to be able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so i can get down
really to the nitty-gritty i can
actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
i only had
an open rate of 2.5 percent so the
industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with a
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products
and somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some of the similar features but
that's what you ideally want to look for
in an email marketing platform so here's
a tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
mail champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lowercase so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's going to get
subject line one and one segment that's
gonna get subject line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is in the campaign
content field so now i have four
parameters and once i've entered in my
variables in those parameter fields i
now have a revised or appended url so my
original url was visit florida.com slash
en dash us slash florida dash
beaches.html my original url i've now
appended that with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with my utm parameters appended to the
url so that's for the first subject line
that's for the audience that's going to
get the first subject line i want to do
another one for the second subject line
so now i'm going to change my campaign
content parameter to subject line
underscore 2. i'm going to copy that url
i'm going to check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line two so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm going to use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
send out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we can start with source
and medium so if i click on source and
medium as my primary dimension here i
can see
mailchimp and the actual date was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i will can i see the medium
being email so now i can see for this
email that was sent out in mailchimp in
may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see
the subject lines in this case if i go
back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder again you're taking a url that
you're going to use in email and then
you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended url
which you can then use in your email so
when the email gets sent you're going to
go back over to google analytics and
you're going to look at the results of
that campaign of that source of that
medium of that content i.e subject line
and so that's why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but what we
really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all digital marketing and
it starts really with google analytics
google analytics is a freemium meaning
that they have a free version that you
can use there is also a paid version of
google analytics
but given the advent of google its
popularity especially in the united
states a majority of users are using the
free version of google analytics so it's
a very popular tool especially for
marketers but there are also other tools
available so it's not just google so we
have adobe analytics which is also
freemium you have kiss metrics you have
spring metrics you have youtube
analytics which is part of google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well
again we want to really measure behavior
we want to measure what's going on with
our website so we want to be able to
identify the location of where our
website visitors are coming from and a
lot of these analytics tools use ip
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
50 new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around
and improve performance so if your
bounce rate is high well how do you
lower bounce rate well we need to do
something about that and analytics tools
will help us identify what's not working
from our site perspective and from a
channel perspective and we can take
action to improve performance so that's
the whole idea behind optimizing our
site's performance so let's jump into
google analytics and let's take a look
at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and
they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
a demographics overview here's a picture
i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 of my
traffic and again this is year to date
that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so
i'm painting a picture about you know
gender and age coming to my website well
i can also look at geo so where
specifically might these people be
coming from so if i go to location under
geo i'm going to be able to see a
breakdown of country or i can even hone
it down to city
or specific location and here i can see
united states is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the us
and then 16 from argentina 13 from
mexico 10 from india so we have a nice
mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i can see
year to date i can see 62 percent are
coming from desktop 35 percent are
coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different
not only experience because the website
should be responsive to the mobile
device but their mindset is going to be
different they're actively looking for
something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we can see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic when this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how that traffic
actually got to the site so if we're
talking about a search engine did they
come to the site via paid search or did
they come to the site via organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium and we can
see specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here i can see
google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
can see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources and mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns
all campaigns and we'll be able to see
the campaign performance if we look at
source and medium we'll be able to see
what campaigns
drove traffic to the website so here i
can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so
that's the campaign reporting and then
also if you have search consoles so we
looked at search console earlier we
talked about seo tools well remember i
said you can link up search console with
google analytics well here's search
console and we could see queries devices
landing pages countries so all the
performance metrics that we could see in
search console because we have it linked
up with analytics we can see it right
here so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're gonna get so that's the
idea behind it we want to make sure that
we're ranking for our coveted keywords
and if we are we want to be able to
measure how many times our listing was
seen and how many times it was clicked
so that's the great thing about you know
google they have a family of products
and those products tend to talk to one
another in the form of google search
console and google ads you can connect
them directly to google analytics so
let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in behavior we have
a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique page use which
is equal to sessions
so i can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so i can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site from
so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where i want to react
and optimize my website performance so i
if i see a page not performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe load time on page then i'm
probably going to optimize it meaning
test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so when we load up the
speed suggestions report what google
does is say hey we know that this page
is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see if i
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that i can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here i could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized i can remove
unused css okay so there are a lot of
different things i can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop i can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
and page load time we see lift and page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example i can see on line six video i
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video start okay so over this
period of time i could see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always revert to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform but you certainly want
to do that so that's where you set up
your events when you set up your events
for your website with a category an
action and label you'll be able to
measure those events in analytics under
behavior under events and the important
thing here is you'll be able to measure
engagement so i'll be able to see how
many people came to the site and how
many people clicked on a button
downloaded a pdf uh submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because we want to be able to
measure conversions on a website so
analytics has four types of conversions
so if i go to admin down at the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have four different types of goals
that i can use now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so if somebody goes to a specific page
like a confirmation page we can turn
that into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation
then analytics is going to fire that
goal as a conversion and we're going to
see a conversion against a different
metric or different dimension like
channel or audience okay so destination
is the second type of goal the third
type of goal is duration so how long did
somebody stay on my website so in this
example if they stayed at least one
minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold type so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter sign ups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by
goal conversion so these are all goals
but if i want to look at for example how
many people from organic search clicked
on the donate now button i could see
that i could see year to date ten 10
users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate now button and
that's comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign mobile
device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the baited the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days
my videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and i've netted 48 subscribers and this
is an overall okay so i can actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published and here i'm
looking at you know total views over
this particular date range i can also
see specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so
here i could see the different traffic
sources so 29 came externally okay here
i could see 25 came within youtube
itself i could see how many times a
video was viewed and played via playlist
via suggested video so i could see
different ways in which the traffic
found my video and actually watched it
here i could see externally how people
were able to find my videos and i could
see 46
found it via google search see some lots
of information here
uh about sources of traffic how the
traffic got to these videos so i could
see then once the traffic found my
videos how many times they actually saw
it and viewed it and then watched it so
that's how many times i was able to
reach viewers via different sources and
then their reaction to that how many
times i saw it and watched it here i can
click on interest viewers so again i
could see the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partner's
playlist was the top playlist so i can
see some interest here in terms of
average view duration and then here we
have build an audience so we can look at
specific audiences if we have them built
in youtube to see how many people
actually watch my videos so here i can
see 88
of the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see
the audience retention over the course
of the video itself i could see the ways
in which people found the video okay
again externally or via youtube search i
could see how many people liked it or
disliked it i could see all sorts of
information on a particular video itself
or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to hone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool social blade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well
moz we looked at moz earlier for keyword
organic moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simplylearn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in their ranking so the reason
why we have this is the top bullet point
is because seo organic search is a
long-term strategy
on-page off-page website very technical
and creative there's a lot going on with
seo a lot going on and
sometimes it takes a long time to rank
for something and a lot of seo does
depend on relevancy relevancy being how
many quality backlinks are linked to you
so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you stack up and so that's why
this is up there as number one we want
to be able to
really take a look at what our
competitors are doing another example
would be hey how much uh traffic a
competitors gaining on certain keywords
this could go either way for paid search
organic search what are competitors
bidding on are they really getting
traffic from those keywords so there are
tools out there that help us leverage
what our competition is doing okay we
can also identify our competitors top
performing content for relevant topics
okay we can determine what our
competitor's website referral traffic is
okay we can pull our competitors data
and compare it with our own campaigns so
lots of tools out there to help you do
this and we may want to track the total
amount of clicks a competitor receives
and how much they pay for each keyword
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
few examples how we can leverage all
these bullet points that we just
discussed and so we're going to start
out with sprout social and sprout social
is a tool i use it's a social media
platform there's a lot of things you can
do with sprout social definitely
generate reports for your social media
platforms you could set up post that get
published at a certain time and day but
there's also one particular tool in here
called listening and so what we could do
is we just put in for example rv rentals
and twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about rv rentals so we could do
this for twitter we could do it facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword rv rentals now if i
want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so rv share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting to or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay i can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
i can scroll down and i can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and i can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so to me it just
gives me a sense in this particular
example on twitter as to what our
competitors doing okay let's turn our
attention to seo so remember that first
bullet point we want to get a sense of
what our competitors are doing when it
comes to backlinks and so moz has a
great tool called link explorer and link
explorer there allows us to actually
compare link profiles so for my domain i
can go ahead and put my competitors
domains in there and definitely get a
sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
cent i can get a sense of page authority
linking domains so i can really do a
comparison across my domain and my
competitors domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has a another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain authority and
page authority then you know i want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them i want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so i can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then i can find
opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see
where
my site intersects with their site and
if it doesn't actually intersect then i
have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitors are
linking now what we can also do is also
take advantage of another report under
moz's link explorer and the discovered
and lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so
really within mods we can get a good
snapshot of what websites are linking to
our competitors we get a good snapshot
of the overall links to our competitor
sites and specifically with sites so the
whole idea is if it's good for our
competitors meaning they're linking from
a site that has good domain authority
and low spam score then it's probably a
site i want to be able to tackle as well
okay so you have discovered and lost
okay you have comparing link profiles
and you have link intersect so those are
three good reports you can leverage
right in moz's link explorer tool now
there's one more report we can leverage
in moz and that's the inbound links
report and so we can go ahead and type
in our competitors domain here and again
we can get a snapshot of what their
domain authority is page authority for
the home page but really this is what
we're after linking domains so this
particular domain has over 9 000 linking
domains so what we can do is actually go
through and see
based on domain authority i could sort
by domain authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here i can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking new york times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9 000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url
is linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so we're not on reddit then
we probably need to be on reddit because
if that's where our competitor is and
they're getting good link juice from
reddit which has a domain authority of
90 then hey if it's good for the goose
it's good for the gander so they say so
inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitor's doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay i can see
here the keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so this particular domain has been
around a long time okay so that's on the
organic side i can flip over to the paid
side and i could see that they are doing
paid search i could see 5 000 plus
keywords they're bidding on okay based
on that what they're actually paying and
then i could see you know some of the
other competitors listed here from a
paid perspective and an organic
perspective i could see the shared
keyword overlap okay now again you can
pay for this because it's freemium and
get some really good insights as to how
your domain compares to your competitors
so i'm using the free version and here
the free version spyfu is just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
i entered in and so i entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at google ads history i could
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then i can see some organic ranking
history here as i keep scrolling down
this overview report so i can see for rv
rent where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spy view
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic-wise and so spy food
is a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if i hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and i hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that i get then i can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
i'm sharing 8
863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and i can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how i stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our locale and if we do that
google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
going to be able to see in this case
just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so if we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry
adjust for your country or region adjust
for the site size meaning how many
sessions you actually get on a daily
basis and then analytics will do the
rest they'll compare you against those
in your industry and so i find this to
be a good tool because it allows me to
stack up our site against those in the
industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some good insight as to what
the competitors are doing and you don't
want to use a tool well look no further
you can always go to google.com okay so
this is how we used to do it back in the
day before all these tools became
available you just typed in a keyword
and we're going to type in rv rentals
and now we're going to be able to see
who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rental so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now i could see i have 163 000 results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have a 163 000 different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a 100 impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position i can see how often
i overlap with my competitors okay i
could see how often i'm above a
particular competitor i could see what
percentage i'm at the top of the page
versus my competitors the absolute top
of page rate and then i can see how
often i outrank my competitors and vice
versa how often my competitors outrank
me so i can see all this good insight as
to what competitors are bidding on the
same keywords i am okay so this is if
you're running google ads okay so if
you're running google ads okay you can
just click on the auction insights
report you can find that the top
navigation just by clicking on campaigns
and by doing so you'll be able to gain
some insights as to where you stack up
from a paid search perspective against
your competitors so let's turn our
attention to paid marketing tools so if
you're doing some advertising on google
bang linkedin you probably want to work
within those platforms as the tool of
choice so
you know if you're doing paid search on
say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage
okay and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes
you have google ads keyword planner of
course both of these are paid if you're
running campaigns okay so bing if you're
running campaigns on bing okay you get
all this good data that you can digest
through some reporting okay you also
have some third-party tools out there
that you also have to pay for in word
stream okay so
word streams a third party tool that you
can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations and devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information
in the case of auction insights as to
how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example adroll okay you have
curtillo celtra is another paid version
of or paid tool you can use in wide
orbit so these are some of the paid
marketing tools you can leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and right customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple of minutes okay so we
want to improve our campaigns by
monitoring our competitors display ads
as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side and if we look at
social okay why what tools can we use on
social well you got facebook ads manager
okay you got ad espresso quiet tweepy
you got all these cool paid search tools
again i usually stick with where i'm
advertising so if i'm advertising on
linkedin or twitter i'm gonna leverage
that platform but just know that there
are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about facebook users how are our
users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly so let's jump right into
google ads and look at some tools
available to us from the search side of
the house so if we're running search
campaigns right in google ads we could
see campaign data we could see keyword
data we could see add data so for
example if i want to see what ads are
performing i'm just going to click on my
ads and extensions okay and here are my
ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in the
google ads uh platform itself now if i
want to look at specific keywords i can
do that so i can see what keywords are
driving traffic and clicks here i could
just sort by clicks and now i could see
not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i could
see the impressions how many people
actually viewed my ad after click typing
in a keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality score
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about the keyword reporting is
that there's some other features
available to me here so here i can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords i can also see a
search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms i can actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or i
want my ad shown for
then i can go ahead and just select it
and i can add it as a negative keyword
okay so that tool is available to you
right in google ads okay then you have
the auction insight so we've reviewed
the auction insights when we're looking
at competitive analysis and so here if
we look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what the overlap
rate is position above rate top of page
absolute top of page right now rank and
share so once we have google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
keywords but there's a cool tool that i
really like and i leverage it for seo
and pay-per-click and that's google's
keyword planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on keyword planner
we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much i
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
i happen to click on that keyword i can
add it to a plan and then once i've
added to a plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay so
now once i've added my keyword to that
plan i can go ahead and see
how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mention this as one
of our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i can see the ad groups
here okay so for example i just want to
turn off all these ad groups i can just
highlight them all and just click status
enabled to pause and i can revert back
if i want to okay so you can make
household changes so here i could see
the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
key words and again i can make changes
at nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick right in google as
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously and being more
efficient on getting things done in the
campaign now if you are working with
somebody else on the campaign you want
to make sure that you get recent changes
so if i say get recent changes to all
campaigns what google editor is going to
do is contact google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here i
can see the changes being download in
editor from google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
write an editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you could do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
network as well as for the display
network right in google ads so if i want
to take a look at a campaign and ad
group on the display network i can just
click on that ad group and i can look at
the ads that are running for that
particular ad group on the display
network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search network you can only
use text ads so here i can look at image
ads and i can see how they're performing
in fact you could even go a step further
and use responsive display ads so google
has responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click-through rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
display network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i can
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i could see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on google ads okay
so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up on youtube okay
if you search for google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do then you could see just how powerful
it is and all the different features
that are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in google ads so let's move into uh
facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we can see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and i
could see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to my expectation so if i
click on more tools and then creatives i
can just simply click on creators and
then i can actually see the creators i
actually have running for that campaign
i selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has
reap different reporting so if i click
on the reports pull down menu you can
see here i could see some standard
reports by add ad set age and gender
and then i can see all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device time of day country etc so if we
just look at age and gender we'll be
able to get a breakout age and gender
here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i can see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i can see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad a lot they're probably going to
tune out to it so that's what makes the
frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see how much we spent so this just gives
you some idea of the type of reporting
that's available in facebook ads manager
now the great thing about facebook
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup uh my dimensions if
i needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you can pick and
choose as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and facebook ads
manager check out the facebook ads
tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj
you as a merchant or you as a publisher
can get in touch with a merchant you as
a merchant can get in touch with a
publisher meaning cj helps bridge the
gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify you know affiliates inflowers
employees other advocates you want to
partner with so again you could be on
the merchant side you could be actually
selling a product and you're going to
want somebody to help you sell that
product somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who you know does sell
reputable brand etc so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so cj and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so
you could set up with terms and
conditions for say 10 off all sales as
an example okay well you're getting a
platform that will help you broker that
contract okay contract terms or program
terms furthermore you're gonna need a
platform to help you track hey is this
affiliate helping me drive traffic or is
this affiliate driving traffic to my
products and is this affiliate helping
me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics okay
so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click epc as an example
most platforms measure epc from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many pressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get
publishers and you want to start
building your base of publishers because
the more publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have publishers who
are promoting your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're gonna finish up
all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up a social media because social
media has so many tools available so
many okay the first one i can think
about here is hootsuite hootsuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here
you basically a base account and then uh
you can use hootsuite to do a lot of
things anything from setting up landing
pages to actually publishing content to
listening hootsuite to me is one of the
most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer
buffers a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
decks been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're going to take a look
at that here in a couple minutes okay
and then you got sprout social sprout
social is another social marketing
platform similar to hootsuite do a lot
of reporting a lot of publishing you can
a lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to smartly efficiently you know
schedule and manage your post okay so
you're not just working likely with just
one platform like facebook you're
probably on a number of different
platforms depending on your business
depending on your bandwidth depending on
what you're selling your products etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be instagram
pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
could manage everything in one place
then these social media marketing
platforms need to be able to make it
easy for you to add and manage different
accounts okay so a lot of them have the
ability for you to add you know not just
one twitter account but multiple twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing so worth its weight will help
you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help drive leads
and sales in other words you're going to
have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place
get a sense of what's been posted what
the engagement is did they purchase etc
and what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook has something called
facebook inside so you'll be able to
actually see you know what's been posted
based on you know the last seven days in
this example how many page views you're
getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads hey you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so i don't have
to log into facebook directly i can see
you know the impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time i can
see my audience growth i can see my
publishing behavior how often my
publishing i can see the top post
individually i can see impressions by
day you know a lot of this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile
write whatever we need to do we could
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so
you want to be able to schedule
accordingly because again when you
schedule something then you want to look
at the behavior of it so it's just as
simple as going from publishing to
reporting and then based on when
something got published you could see
the reaction of it and react to it so
another thing here that i like about
it's about social hootsuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location or radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account so i can pick and choose the
profile that i want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here
okay i can get a sense of when it was
used and i can view it on a calendar i
can add label for it so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
could see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received
okay so i want to be able to see how my
particular platform is performing over a
period of time so i can look at reach a
lot profile views website clicks okay so
i can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i want to do i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions comments saves etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter uh
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the qriket world cup
you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that
friday feeling in their tweets and so
the whole idea behind you know tweetdeck
it serves up a interesting overview so
to speak of not only your account but
you know a specific topic or what's
trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social
you know facebook insights so it does
cover in more detail some of what we
covered on these social media marketing
tools so take a look at how to start
social media marketing so we covered a
lot of different marketing tools digital
marketing tools everything from seo to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video seo for
example so vid iq you know we want to
use vid iq to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plug-in if you
will
so i can go and take a look at a
specific specific video and see how many
hours it's been watched how many views
minutes watch subscribers etc you know
the great thing here i can look at the
entire entire account so
i can get good insights into
my video or my entire account here just
by adding in the vid iq extension into
my chrome browser so vid iq actually
does give you some really really good
insights into not only your account but
the video and so recommend vid iq
because it's good for video seo okay
there's also tools related to content
optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for content optimization you know
there's also other key reddit but you
know there's keyboard planner uh in
google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a google
ads platform and so if you don't have
google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to google's keyword planner
so having a third party keyword tool
will pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
target okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with
the free account you can have hotjar
measure the heat map not only the heat
map but the click mapping the scrolling
of a particular page and so here you can
see we're looking at a particular page
here so hotjar allows me to you know see
on that page where people are clicking
um i can also see where people are
moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i can see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking
mostly if i switch over to move mode
then i can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
mouse and then i have my scroll analysis
so i could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to ten thousand page views
with the free version you can measure up
to 2000 pages and so 2000 page use
allows you to get some insight as to
what people are clicking on or where
they're moving or how they're scrolling
on a particular page and so i definitely
recommend hot jar they also do funneling
they also do forms polls lots of other
tools available in hotjar so hotjar.com
is a tool i would recommend as well so
one final tool and i'd be remiss if i
didn't mention it and that's google
optimized so google optimize is a google
platform that allows you to a b test and
so a b testing means that you have an
original page and you're changing one
element on that page to see which one
performs better and so with google
optimize it's just very easy to set up
to run and the whole point of google
optimize and a b testing is to improve
website performance so here you can see
i have an account set up and optimize
you can see we're running one test here
and we're just testing one element
versus the original so we move photos to
the top of the page the original didn't
have the photos to the top of the page
and so we can go into reporting here
google optimize does all the heavy
lifting and so here you can see
we can look at bounces or we can look at
you know basically a measure the test up
against the metric that's important to
our business and again the whole point
is to improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests then that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
google optimize is a tool that i would
recommend
carl has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is seo to solve this
issue i have a few important tracking
factors that karl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well
before we get started with the ranking
factors let me first explain what seo is
seo is the practice of getting traffic
from organic search results on a search
engine like google bing etc depending
upon the keywords search engines rank
websites based on what content they
consider most relevant to users
without further ado let me tell you the
top 5 ranking factors which can help
karl to rank his website
first is content quality then it's page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure
next is ssl certificates
and finally its backlinks which is the
most important ranking factor let's have
a look at good content quality a good
content quality is an essential factor
that helps a website to rank on google
google ranks content that completely
answers a user's query
in our case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction
this article on the best vanilla cake
i've ever had is a good example of
having a comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include lsi keywords in your content
in seo lsi stands for latent semantic
indexing they're used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serves an easy way to look for lsi
keywords is on google serve some of the
lsi keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link equity across the site
it is important to create a simple
internal website link structure
in the below example a bot crawls on web
page 2 by following internal link of the
web page 1. next add suitable images
with descriptive alt text here using
relevant images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your webpage is completely
crawlable for bots as it will enhance
website ranking
here as you see this website is high up
on the google search because every web
page in it is crawlable by bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience
for a mobile friendly design always
prefer short and crisp sentences for
easy reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile friendly designs are shown here
and most importantly update the content
regularly by doing this search engine
rearranges your site's ranking for
example the sally's baking addiction
cake recipe blog ranks at number one on
google the reason it updates content
regularly
next we have page speed page speed
defines how fast the content of a web
page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a page
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
paid speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of etiquette memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
next use a content distribution network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content at multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code minify
files if your website has numerous css
and javascript file you can minify and
combine them
google says slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and url
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and url is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe carl cake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and callcake.com is
the brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
now talking about urls always refer a
well-structured short and simple url
according to backlinko analysis short
urls tend to rank better than long urls
moving on to our fourth ranking factor
let's talk about ssl certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost in rankings https
is used for secure communication over a
computer network
as you can see here google confirms
https as one of the ranking factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling dns sec protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture
the famous digital marketer neil patel
says the better your site structure the
better your chance of ranking higher in
the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
bots to find and index all of the web
page
a good site structure results in good
use experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are
creating a logical hierarchy structure
which means a good site architecture not
only makes content easier to find but
also helps to gain traffic
include site maps so that the bots can
easily access and index the content
code your site navigation in css or html
because these two languages are easy to
code and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last ranking factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
authority
in seo the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
linkedin etc
participating in high pr q a sites like
quora and post answers to the questions
related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using seo and seo is
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of seo so
let's get right to it and talk about why
seo so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and you're curious why am
i not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so
what kind of keywords do you want to
rank for that's really what we're
talking about when we talk about usage
of keywords what keywords do you want to
rank for and how do we work those
keywords into the content another reason
is port link building practices and
really that means our other blog posts
or other websites linking to you also
are you linking to other pages on your
website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and
your blog post isn't loading fast enough
well if you look at it this way think
about it if you're google would you
really want to rank a website or blog
post in this example number one on
google rankings if that particular page
loaded very slow no you wouldn't because
when somebody clicked on that link in
organic search and went to your website
they're going to have a bad experience
because the page is going to load slow
so google doesn't want their users to
have a bad experience you don't want
your users to have a bad experience and
so that's why web page load time is a
critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure that our web pages load
fast and then your user experience is
not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people who are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice clean blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just made mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank the those pages that they've
indexed from number one to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and what these
bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index so based on
this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i can see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search uh we don't want
to get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where google
counts the 1 million 10 000 results and
so that's the whole idea behind crawling
and indexing google is able to cross
simply learn's website and based on all
the pages that they gather they're going
to make those pages available in organic
search so if you type in a keyword and
your web page is not available for
indexing then you're never going to show
up for that keyword so that's why it's
important to make sure your website is
available for crawling and indexing and
so when a user types a query on search
google search the most relevant websites
that are in google's index are going
appear in the search results so in the
example i gave uh was simply learn well
simply learn is the brand name of the
company simply learn so there's a lot of
relevancy there so that's why you see
simply learn show up here organically
number one like we mentioned about what
is seo and why seo we talked about that
user experience so there's a lot of
factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time is fast meaning these pages
load very fast for the end user and
google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in india the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the united states why
because google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously
but it's not real time syncing so if you
do a search in india you may not see
exactly the same thing because both
search engines the google and india and
the google in the us are may not be
exactly synced up so
an example would be you know if you're
looking for cafe so if you search a cafe
and say san francisco you're going to
see different results now if you do a
search for cafes in mumbai you're going
to see different results there's going
to be local search here at the top there
may be some paid search but again you
may see different results because one
location but two google search engines
in india and united states google.com
aren't exactly synced up exactly at the
same exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of seo now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page seo and off-page
seo so first we're going to talk about
on-page seo so on-page seo is nothing
more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in seo keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example of how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google's going to do is
they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we can see a trend here that for
each particular month over the last 12
months we can see how much volume this
particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if i go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 uh per month on average and so
what i want to do is get a more clear
picture of the competition and so what
you could actually do is type in the
syntax all in title and then colon and
then your keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist and when i
do that i get a different result here i
can see only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
hall in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for a number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again
you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example
going back here to our search how to
become a digital marketing specialist we
saw that every one of these listings had
that keyword in the title tag and the
title tag is important because that's
what users who use google search see
first when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking
on your site and the whole idea behind
internal linking is it also allows users
to navigate through the site naturally
so when i say naturally they don't
always have to refer back to the top
navigation they can naturally and
seamlessly go from one relevant article
or page to another and so that's the
whole idea behind link building and
internal link building it allows google
to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other
relevant related keywords that's going
to be more natural and so that's what we
mean on natural language processing we
want to choose keywords that are more
natural to the content you're writing so
instead of the keyword digital marketing
maybe we want to talk about the types of
digital marketing or digital marketing
examples or what is a digital marketing
strategy or how to become a digital
marketing specialist so those are all
relevant keywords to digital marketing
and more relevant to the content because
if you try to rank for the keyword
digital marketing again it's probably
going to be a little bit broad probably
more competition and not as relevant to
your content and as a result probably
not a good user experience so think
about some other keywords that you could
optimize and rank for and that goes back
to the keyword research that's why the
keyword research is so important because
it allows us to identify
other keywords and the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one is an html
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that site map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to
simplylearn.com and simply type in say
sitemap.xml just as an example i'm going
to get this particular page and this
particular page displays two xml
sitemaps so these site maps are there
for google to go ahead and crawl and
nothing more than a list of all the
pages on your website and so this is a
quick and easy way for google to get a
hold of all those pages so that they can
index them and that's the whole idea
behind seo you want to be able to have
google index all the content you want to
be found for for the keywords you want
to be found for so it all starts with
the sitemap so let's go from on-page seo
which in recap is basically optimizing
certain elements on your website so that
you are relevant for a particular
keyword and that meant updating the
title tag the meta description the url
the headers choosing the right keywords
to put into the content having internal
linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on-page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on onpage but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page seo and so off-page seo is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember i talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking for off-page seo we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
website's recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page seo synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website
then it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain authority and so
what i mean by high domain authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain authority is going to improve
and when our domain authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off-page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website linked back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you could share your content
with them they can share their content
with you and generally that's how it
works naturally anyway in the web sphere
if somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents are quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one of two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
to two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural
naturally linking from one page to
another not only does it help google
understand and crawl all the web pages
on your website but it's good for the
end user it's good user experience and
certainly last but something i didn't
talk about does take time to rank your
content so remember the process you're
going to write your content you're going
to choose keywords you're going to
change the elements on that page for
those keywords and all the while you're
going to make sure google can crawl that
content and when they crawl they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo and off-page
seo then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's
user-friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for relevant keywords and so
the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's a
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
fact based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really
the underlying factor here is that all
keywords in your keyword research should
be relevant so you need to understand
what those keywords are so are they
relevant to the content that you want to
be found for if they are then really the
two factors you want to look for is the
volume how much volume or traffic each
keyword has associated with it and then
the competition how many other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competition is associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and they are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally
have very high search volume that means
that if somebody types in italian
restaurants then there's going to be a
large amount of volume with that meaning
that
generally a lot of people type in the
keyword italian restaurants however with
high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that if you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because
they're probably a lot of websites who
are in front of you who want to be
ranked and found for the same keyword so
the whole idea with short tail keywords
is it's a lot of visibility it's a lot
of traffic a lot of volume but also a
lot of competition and generally the
underlying factor here is that if you
are ranked for a very broad or short
tail keyword like italian restaurants
then chances are it's not going to be as
relevant so if you get the traffic to
your website then chances are the
conversion's not necessarily going to
happen because we don't necessarily know
the mindset of somebody typing in a very
short tail generic keyword like italian
restaurants they could be doing research
on italian restaurants they could be a
chef who's trying to get recipes for
italian food it could be a tourist
looking for italian restaurants in a
different city or it could be a person
just looking for italian restaurants
near their location or where they're
living and so there's a lot of different
factors with short tail keywords so you
just don't know because it's so generic
and because it's so generic if you do
get the traffic for that generic keyword
then the chances of the conversion are
going to be lower than say if it's a
more specific relevant keyword so let's
take an example
of a short tail keyword let's just stick
with italian restaurants so i'm going to
go to
a tool
called moz and while moz has a tool
called the keyword explorer and within
moz so if you go to moz.com and then use
the keyword explorer you can get an idea
of how much volume and competition are
associated with a particular keyword so
in this example we're using italian
restaurants it's a very broad keyword we
could see that the monthly volume
is between 70 000 and 118 000 per month
okay so that means for a particular
keyword in the united states on a search
engine you're going to get about 70 000
to 118 000 people who type in that
keyword and so if we were to look at the
difficulty of that keyword you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of 1 to 100 it's got to score 43 so it's
fairly difficult however if you notice
the click-through rate is very high so
moz estimates that we'll have a 40
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer tail
keywords however if you want the
visibility then you want to use short
tail keywords if you want the conversion
then you want to switch over to longer
tail keywords so longer tail keywords
are more specific they usually consist
of more than three keywords so tie in
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high case and
points if we go back to moz and then we
look at the keyword explorer and we'd
actually type in italian restaurants and
let's just say
orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you can see very very little search
volume in fact
so little volume there's 11 to 50 okay
so that means on average that this
keyword generates 11 to 50 queries a
month so very low compared to our short
tail keyword italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an italian restaurant in say
orlando florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in a time in florida
branded shoes in florida something very
specific is going to generate probably a
higher conversion rate than something
more generic so that's the trade-off and
so when to use long-tail keywords well
we want to use long-tail keywords and
for targeting pages with a product or
specific article so if we're interested
in that particular conversion then
longer tail keywords are likely more the
way we want to go versus something more
generic which means if you're using a
generic shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
when you're setting up your brand and
you need to make sure it reaches the
right audience and provide the best
results there's really only one place to
turn to it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising so we're
gonna start out with what are google ads
well google ads used to be called google
adwords and it's been around a good
while almost 20 years now so really
google has grown at a really rapid pace
it's become one of google's main sources
of revenue uh you could say probably in
the 90 percentile of its revenue comes
from google ads and when we say google
ads we mean people who pay for
advertising on google.com so google ads
really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you a
also may hear google ads or ppc referred
to as cost per click or cpc or sponsored
search really what it comes down to it's
a model so when you advertise on
google.com and somebody clicks on your
ad basically you're paying google for
they click okay so it's just really a
business model where an advertiser pays
google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
i want to advertise my business i can go
to google ads and say google place my ad
on google.com and then my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as i pay google a
fee so google ads is just an online
advertising platform developed by google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads they can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobile's involved so you got
all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have the little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ad is
going to show up somebody clicks on it
you pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic in return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day in fact here
in the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar with their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly measure our performance so
with google we're paying cost per click
and so based on that model you know we
can certainly measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that okay and if that
traffic turns out to be a lead we can
measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we can
certainly measure our performance all
the way down the keyboard level and can
we can measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
its high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what i always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider google
ads because as we shown here in our
example if i go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to
bid on the keyword what are google ads
why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for a particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again
search is really the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when i say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember search is there
to respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are it's going to be a highly
relevant visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on google for google.com so
google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let google do the
heavy lifting why not let google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google
owns youtube so you can run
advertisements video advertisements on
youtube so they could be standalone or
they can be inserted into other
streaming video content as say pre-roll
meaning people are going to look at your
ad before actually watching the actual
video they went to youtube for so you
have a lot of different options with
video advertisements on youtube so the
other ad format you have on google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they can see
the brand and so it's an opportunity for
you to really drive high quality traffic
to your site with the opportunity to
convert somebody at a very high rate so
shopping ads are really good because it
prevents unwanted clicks if somebody
clicks on that ad they're definitely
interested so let's take a look on
search to see how that looks so if i go
to google search and i just type in
running shoes so my search results are
going to list not only some paid ads but
a lot of different options on shopping
ads so here i could certainly scroll
around and see all the different brand
names i could see the price point if i
hover over it i can actually see you
know some other information about it
like reviews return policy so if i
actually click on this ad chances are
i'm going to buy it otherwise why would
i click on the ad as an end user and so
that's the great thing about shopping
ads it gives you the advertiser an
opportunity to really get your products
in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly really
giving google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also appears under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so
shopping ads allow you to really
showcase your products on google search
to those looking for that particular
product so it's really a great option
with google you also have call ads so
when we say call ads really call only
ads are great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business and
google can track that they can track how
many people click on your number and
even turn that into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business it's wise to go ahead
and set up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to
where is google showing your ads i
showed you an example of google search
so we looked at text ads we looked at
shopping ads on google search network so
google search network really allows you
to advertise on google search so with
google search if i go back to google
search and i go to all i typed in
running shoes okay here i can see
shopping ads here i can see a couple of
text ads so you have the opportunity if
you're running only text ads to show at
the top and if you're not at the top
then google will place you at the bottom
so it really depends on the keyword that
somebody's querying in google search so
it really depends on how many people are
advertising and so what google does if i
didn't have any shopping ads here google
will list a maximum of four text ads at
the top and at the bottom any other ads
that weren't shown at the top will get
placed at the bottom so ideally if
you're running text ads on google you
want to make sure you're always at the
top and i would say between positions
one and three you always want to make
sure you're at the top okay so you can
certainly measure that remember google
had has measured performance so you can
measure everything about your ad so if
you're going to advertise on google with
a text ad you want to make sure you're
always at the top so let's have a look
at the different types of search
networks that google ads is affiliated
with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search
so if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device also so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and
they could see organic search results so
for example this is what an ad would
look like so let me show you what that
looks like on google search so if we go
for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see
some search ads here these ads appear
above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position
why because again i can see the logo add
here okay so i can see simply learn
using three headlines i can see simply
learn using there are two description
lines here and i can see simply learn
using some other extensions with the ad
now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity
to be at the very top of the search
result or in the top three above local
listings and above organic results now
if i change my search query and typed in
coffee in san francisco my search
results are going to be completely
different i'm going to see local
listings here okay so this is tied to
google my business not google ads okay
so this is completely different so don't
don't mix this up with running ads on
google search so google my business is
tied to local listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely google local
listings above organic results okay and
if i go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing i'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to trump any other type of
results on google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between youtube
to amazon to new york times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if i go to say
ask.com and type in classes on digital
marketing it's a completely different
search engine but i can see the same ad
for simply learn so i can see same i
could see a different headline here
actually but i could see the description
and i could see some site link
extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see
multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and i could see those
over
over organic listings so
these are google search partner listings
so you can opt in to be on other partner
sites that google or other sites that
google has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the new yorktimes.com or
webmd or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell google hey this is the site i want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the display
network so if you don't want to
advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on google's
display network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so
you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so
retargeting as we said earlier is really
reaching out to people who have already
been to your website and didn't perform
a particular function that you wanted
them to perform meaning somebody came to
your website from paid search on
google.com and they went to page a and
then they left so you really wanted them
to go to page b add a product to a
shopping cart and check out and purchase
that product however if they didn't do
that you could certainly run ads knowing
that they've been to page a and page b
and you can offer up that specific ad to
that person who's been to your website
and so that's what retargeting really is
all about and you can retarget on
google's display network so remarketing
your product to people who previously
visited your your website or even your
app allows you to really get your ad in
front of a qualified audience and so you
could take advantage of analytics so
google's ads has all the information you
need so let's actually take a look at
some of these options in google ads for
the display network so if i actually go
to google ads and i actually go to
display campaigns i can see i have a lot
of different options available to me so
if i click on keywords for example okay
i can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
display network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example
by age range based on my campaign how
many clicks how many impressions
impressions are how many times my ads
been seen click-through rate meaning the
rate at which people see my ad and are
clicking on my ad how much i'm paying
per click cpc is cost per click total
cost and conversions how many
conversions am i getting so i could see
all this data available to me in google
ads so it's a very powerful platform for
measuring performance imagine it's the
year 2004.
this is phil
phil's looking to release a book and set
up a blog he's sure that he'd be
successful but he's only worried about
one thing
he doesn't know how to ensure that his
book reaches the right target audience
who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads billboards
radio direct mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved
now let's have a look at the same
scenario in the present day alongside
traditional forms of advertising phil
would have access to digital marketing
a form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails etc among
these types social media marketing cot
fields eye
social media marketing would give phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertise his
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about his
book increase the interaction with his
audience it's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos but over
time phil began to notice that not a lot
of people were being exposed to his
content
phil needed to advertise his content for
that he would need to use the
advertising options provided by the
social media platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text
they also have a call to action that
encourages user interaction
bill could use images from his book
advertise websites that sell his book
and more then there are text and post
ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more and in
time phil began to see an increase in
the number of viewers coming to his
social media page and by extension his
blog
he also saw an increase in the number of
people who bought his book
greatly increasing his audience
here are some things he learned one to
set goals that were quantitative smart
and follow a constant deadline two to
understand his audience by engaging and
connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
four
using tools like buzzsumo ifttt buffer
and more for lead generation creating
email lists setting buyer personas and
more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos
but how did phil get so good at social
media marketing
phil had taken up simplylearn's digital
marketing course it was thanks to this
course that phil had the skills and
training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too
by clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today i mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton i mean those were the ways to get
your product and message out there a lot
of advertising in those yellow pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise vfx just a few
decades ago so these were all the ways
in which people had to get their product
and service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service that engages
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're gonna answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can rise above
the rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
and what we mean by viral is spreading
like wildfire one user sending it to
another as rapidly as can be and before
you know it you get you know millions of
views and millions of likes i mean
that's the power of social media
marketing so why do we want to do social
media marketing and i think we just
answered some of those questions but
let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel social
media marketing allows us to really put
our brand in a good light in a good
position in front of the right eyeballs
so it allows us to really improve our
brand by pushing out the appropriate
content in front of the appropriate
people social media is a great channel
for that we can look to conversion rates
so if we are pushing a product and
service in front of the right eyeballs
and we are building up a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see it every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase
we can certainly leverage social media
marketing for seo for search engine
rankings it's about off-page seo it's
about posting content on social media
platforms to build up some link juice
okay so there is some inherent benefits
to working seo and social media side by
side it's cost effective well if you're
posting content on twitter or facebook
it doesn't cost you anything it just
takes a little bit of time and
creativity now if you want to go ahead
and do some advertising on these
platforms yes it's going to cost you but
you'd be surprised not going to be as
costly as say other search platforms
like say google or bing where you're
actually paying for keywords and paying
per click for those keywords so social
media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product and service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service i mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing today we are
going to talk about all the different
ads that facebook has to offer so
introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to share your product and
your brand with users who you think are
going to buy your product or associate
with your brand and on facebook you can
do that a number of different ways
specifically in somebody's news feed and
specifically that person's news feed
that again is interested potentially
interested in your brand your product so
there's a lot of ways to advertise and a
lot of reasons why you want to advertise
so i just mentioned one of the reasons
hey it's an opportunity for you to reach
out to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27 billion in the
third quarter of 2018 and so when we say
spend a lot of time we mean going to
that facebook profile at least once a
day okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout
the day checking their news feed on
facebook facebook also enables you the
advertiser to find the perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on facebook and targeted
audience so it's a platform that allows
you to put your product in front of
people based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about facebook is it's
lesser spend greater reach and what do
we mean by that well traditionally
facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's newsfeed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
as our advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your servicer product but if they didn't
go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way we
want to be able to reach out to people
who aren't fully committed at that point
in time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad and the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be
you know a brand that is trying to woo
my business okay so they know that
somebody that i'm associated with or
maybe i fit their demographic so they're
targeting my newsfeed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you haven't noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if i go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so i can't miss it if i'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see simply learn has a example
of a carousel ad where they're
showcasing their different courses so
this allows users to view a range of all
your different products and services if
you have multiple products and services
to offer then the carousel ads would be
a good option for you so in addition to
the carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are interactive it's a good
way to really showcase your product your
brand your service and the great thing
about the video ads is they can go from
just a few seconds all the way up to you
know two minutes or excuse me all the
way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you can put your
brand and product out there in not just
a few seconds but you know really tell a
nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your carousel ad
so facebook also allows us to
advertise something called lead ads and
what lead ads allow us to do is obtain
user details okay so we can acquire or
get an email address or phone number
from somebody who's interested in our
product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really
put your best images out there with a
really strong call to action just like
you see here with the simply learn
example okay so they're showcasing you
know they're different classes and then
they have the get started today call to
action to really punctuate the slideshow
ad so what's interesting is you can
really gauge a person's interest by
throwing different products or images
out there you know you can really
immerse a user's experience here by
showing different different images and
then the last type of ad on facebook is
called the collection ad and so these
ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you can see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential
more than 7 billion revenue has been
generated from instagram mobile and it's
home to more than 2 million advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to instagram's
parent company facebook instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by facebook ads with
this you can advertise to people based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a url to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your brand's website or a page for a
particular product
make sure to track this link as well to
see how much traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption hashtags videos goes live on
what day date or time a consistent post
schedule will enable you to make the
most out of instagram it'll also keep
your audience engaged and also give you
access to historical posts if you want
to repost your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
facebook
like audience segmentation based on
likes interactions buying habits and
more
you also have a variety of ad formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from
bodyshop in which they're using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted earthly tones
with a low key editing style
your content must feel down to earth and
your brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and a
somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell
now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and by your
products
your captions can tell stories that can
help your brand appear more human and
build deeper connections with your
audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tells stories about
a different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues
that's the kind of stories you should
tell with your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags using the right hashtags can
make the difference between your posts
showing up on the explore tab for
everyone to see and it getting lost in
the sea of content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven
take advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content and takes
advantages of their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads
most instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads carousels are a combination
of images and videos and instagram
stories that enable you to combine
images and videos to create visually
attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest ralph lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments you can
give away a product or a service which
enables you to boost engagement and
brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned brands need to be partnered with
contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to the savvy
marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews
another new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels instagram's answer to
tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
instagram engagement so let's talk about
how to create a youtube ad so this is
going to require
some access to google ads and we'll go
over that in a few minutes here but
first we need to think about setting up
a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign to get eyeballs you know we
want to pay cost per 1000 impressions or
we want to run some actionable type ads
to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video out
here that is going to show on youtube
and to our target audience so
or whether it be a bumper ad that's only
going to be six seconds long we need to
be able to figure out what type of ad we
want to run so here i am in google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
youtube
we need to make sure that
we're choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video
basically what we're doing is we're
going to tell google we want to go ahead
and set up some video ads on youtube and
so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable cpm model so we're going to
go ahead and
you know check one of these types of
campaign types or ad types so we're
going to click continue and then once we
do that you know we're gonna get
prompted to
you know move forward with selecting our
ad so you can see here after i set up my
campaign now i'm just gonna go through
some of the settings for my ad and i'm
gonna give it a campaign name a budget
okay when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're going to focus
on costs per 1000 impressions and then
here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with youtube videos so
we also have the option to select video
partners on the display network so that
means that if you want your video to
show on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here notice you also have this
option available if you're running
certain types of ads on youtube we're
running those bumper ads so bumper ads
aren't available on search results so
i'm going to stick with the video
partners okay youtube videos and here we
can get into some other specifics like
language country the type of inventory
so here you can see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what google recommends we want
to show our ads on content that's
appropriate for most ads okay so we can
go expanded or limited so we're going
with the recommended here okay and then
when we go down we're going to have an
ad group so when you create a campaign
you can have an ad group so with an ad
group that means that we can have a more
or less a video in every ad group we
have but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're gonna go ahead and set up
you know this ad group here and here's
where it gets interesting and important
because here is where we can start
targeting our audience so here we got
demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
youtube videos or we can go with youtube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember in this
example we're going to bumper ads so
we're looking at about six seconds and
once we do that then that's pretty much
the campaign but i just want to stress
here that when you're setting it up
ahead of time you want to make sure you
identify what the campaign goal is and
then that's going to align with the type
of video you're going to run and then
once you choose that type of video then
it just comes down to where you want
that ad to be and who you're targeting
so it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
youtube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing those
ads and so going back to what i was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and choose the ad placements and
remove them okay so let me show you an
example of what that means so if i'm
back in google i'm gonna go to my
campaign and i'm gonna select placements
and here i could see placements but then
i'm going to select where my ads show
and so this is important you want to be
able to scan the list of placements
where the ad was shown so if you don't
like one of the placements on youtube
you can always select it edit it and
exclude it from the campaign or record
so that's really the key is you want to
be able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing ad placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta so
again depending on the ad type you know
if it's a true view ad 20 seconds long
you want to have a call to action you
want to maybe even have your domain name
at the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting to specify who gets to see
your ad and who doesn't okay so that
goes back to your settings so you can
pick and choose who your target audience
is you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be as an other
setting you can use closed captioning in
your ads to make it more interactive so
that way people can actually see or read
what the ad is all about just to make it
a bit more interactive you can always
perform a b testing on your ads so if
you have one ad version you can create
another one just to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always a positive okay so if
you're paying too much maybe think about
reducing your bids so if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids at the ad group
level so reduce bids in areas where you
see lower performance so in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that
really you want to make sure that your
ad is you know is with the end viewer
you don't want to put out an ad that
isn't going to give somebody you know a
good feeling after they've watched it
okay so you want to make sure viewers
find the content relevant so if they
don't find it relevant then that means
your engagement rate and your engagement
is probably going to be low so you want
to take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad to try to make sure your ad
conveys your brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any ad you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise you know people are
going to be turned off or not engaged
and just going to go ahead and skip it
anyway so you want to make sure you get
the purpose of it right up front and out
of the way okay you can also include
visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads yes i mean click-through
rate engagement rate all of those are
indicators whether the ad is of good
quality or not with the end user and
when i say good quality i mean do they
find it
did they find it interesting if so
they're going to click and if you don't
have good click-through rates or good
engagement rates then you definitely
want to try doing something different to
the ad like adding those audio
components or other visuals that could
be appealing to the end user so go ahead
and and test some of those out with a b
because you have nothing to lose but
higher or lower engagement rates or
lower click-through rates so you want to
be able to improve those metrics
improving those metrics means trying
some different components on different
ads so let's take a look at a case study
if you will and let's focus on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift products so in september last
year 2018
talk about how you can optimize your
youtube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing those
ads and so going back to what i was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and choose the ad placements and
remove them okay so let me show you an
example of what that means so if i'm
back in google i'm going to go to my
campaign and i'm going to select
placements and here i can see placements
but then i'm going to select where my
ads show and so this is important you
want to be able to scan the list of
placements where the ad was shown so if
you don't like one of the placements on
youtube you can always select it edit it
and exclude it from the campaign or
record so that's really the key is you
want to be able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing at placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your
domain name at the end of the video so
at least somebody knows where to go so
you always want to have a call to action
with your video ad you want to use
negative targeting to specify who gets
to see your ad and who doesn't okay so
that goes back to your settings so you
can pick and choose who your target
audience is you can pick and choose who
you don't want your audience to be as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ad is all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive okay you can always perform
a b testing on your ads so if you have
one ad version you can create another
one just to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always a positive okay so if
you're paying too much maybe think about
reducing your bids so if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids at the ad group
level so reduce bids in areas where you
see lower performance so in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that
really you want to make sure that your
ad is you know is with the end viewer
you don't want to put out an ad that
isn't going to give somebody you know a
good feeling after they've watched it
okay so you want to make sure viewers
find the content relevant so if they
don't find it relevant then that means
your engagement rate and your engagement
is probably going to be low so you want
to take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any ad you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise you know people are
going to be turned off or not engaged
and just going to go ahead and skip it
anyway so you want to make sure you get
the purpose of it right up front and out
of the way okay you can also include
visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads and you want to be able to
you know measure the ad performance
based on the metrics we discussed i mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when i say good quality i mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting if so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a b testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some asian
markets european markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders uh from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so their global
brand they really wanted to take a
different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so
what they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they wanted want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that youtube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to youtube and let's just take a look
at this one minute ad here 53 second ad
buy super dry
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting
the jacket you're pulling the jacket
your play pal and posing
in this jacket
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see that
you know it was had some particular
goals there and so super dry is pretty
well known so it probably wasn't built
around brand awareness per se it was
probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video it was
definitely not a bumper ad because
bumper ads are six seconds so it was
definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender uh some
younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million but the more
important thing
is because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a 138 percent increase in brand lip
i mean the jacket ad so it was a pretty
successful campaign see as well
choreographed good audio good video just
well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers
under their belt because of this ad
alone so that's the power of video okay
so you're able to know who your target
audience is you can go out and target
them with a cool video and given that
youtube is vast then you can really take
advantage of a lot of their ads so what
they probably did again was those
trueview in-stream ads uh with a cost
per view uh through a skippable video ad
format and they they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on youtube so they took advantage
of all youtube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to target the
length of the ad
and
given that their product or selling a
product or promoting a product they will
take advantage of the trueview shoppable
ad format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again based on the numbers that they're
reporting and so
basically that's the power of youtube
getting out in front of your audience
with a really good
video ad targeting an audience taking
advantage of different formats today
we're going to talk about how to
increase instagram followers today's
webinar we're going to have some tips
and and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started
and talk a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user base growth of more than 300
year-over-year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform nat which is now owned by
facebook has become really really
popular a good place for you if you have
your own company if you have your own
brand if you have your own product it's
a good place for you to really showcase
that service that product that brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use and the wide reach it has for you
in which to tell your story as i
mentioned there are lots of photos
shared today close to seven billion
dollars revenue generated through
instagram mobile so on top of everything
i just said there's a lot of e-commerce
going on here too so instagram is a
platform in which there's e-commerce
integrated within the platform so as a
business who offers up products you can
actually generate revenue for yourself
on the flip side instagram which is
owned by facebook has an opportunity to
sell advertising space on instagram so
instagram is an e-commerce platform to
say the least in fact instagram is
because it's so popular because it's
part of facebook's advertising platform
they're more than two million
advertisers on instagram so amongst all
those stories videos and photos and
hashtags you'll see some ads and then
because you'll see ads because you'll
see users you're going to see businesses
it's just good place to really set up
shop and really tell your story through
the world of photos and videos so 25
million plus businesses have already
migrated over to instagram and that's
growing and growing and growing so it's
an opportunity for you to work with
other businesses so the arrow is
definitely pointing up on instagram
there's a lot going on here easy to use
application especially when it comes to
photos and videos so we're gonna go
through some tips and tricks today and
we're gonna talk about everything there
is to know about instagram and how to
increase your followers so let's take a
look at tip one here so because
instagram is an application everything
you do on it is through the application
now you could certainly view a web page
version on it but you really can't do
much out of that so if i go to my
instagram account for example using my
desktop i could see my profile and i can
edit my profile to a degree but
everything you're doing is through the
application so when it comes to that tip
one here is take advantage of your bio
so regardless of what industry you are
you're in who you are you really want to
have a clear and concise and compelling
bio why because this is your
introduction to the world you want
people to know who you are and because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not going to follow you
so this is where it all starts you need
to take advantage of your bio have a
clear and concise bio and have a link to
your website or some contact information
so to me this is where it all starts you
gotta have a bio because that's what
people are gonna look at and they're
gonna decide whether to follow you or
not based on primarily that bio that's
where it all starts so make sure you
have a good bio that's tip number one so
you'll have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most instagram users are on mobile
so if you're going to put a link to your
website and somebody's on the instagram
app and they see your bio and they like
it and you have a link to your website
make sure that landing page they go to
is mobile optimized so tip number two
everything you do on instagram when it
comes to posting evolves around hashtags
so that's the backbone of the platform
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like twitter or
facebook pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
instagram is no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so hashtags are
there to help users find your content so
you want to start out by using hashtags
that are relevant to your business so if
you're in the food industry you're gonna
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags that describe your brand and
also are being searched on instagram so
what does that mean that means do a
little bit of homework on instagram you
know see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't mean really
mean somebody's going to be interested
in what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
day to post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 p.m on thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time a day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted and engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see what they've
posted in terms of videos and images and
i can like or comment so just doing
something as simple as this gets you an
opportunity to engage with somebody who
can then turn around and follow you so
tip five pay for sponsored posts and
product reviews so a number of ways you
could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you could find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your cr credibility because
you're connecting with somebody who has
a large audience as well so do a little
bit of homework find people out there in
your industry who has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use instagram stories to attract
followers and grow your user base a
story is a really big feature on
instagram so what stories could be used
for is just show footage of an
environment so it could be your office
it could be your home it could be you
know the playground it could be the golf
course it could be anywhere that you
want to show village of so you want to
post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog posts you
can post positive user reviews so these
are all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlight serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your content's
about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote and promote your
product highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential followers so it teases what
the content's about it creates a trailer
so to speak for your brand and promote
your product so use highlights and again
any users out there who have good
examples of highlights go ahead and put
those in the content section or comment
section uh right below this video so
remember stories have only a 24 hour
life span so highlights can be used to
give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the contents about it promotes the
product and it really kind of
accentuates that story tip number nine
ask for followers so sometimes people
need a little push before they can
follow you on instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers in the caption
the comment section even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know i got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post you know
really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engagers then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if if it
is popular then go ahead and say hey
this is a popular post you know think
about following me or put something in
the comment section you want to do it
kind of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just work it in to some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence and asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on youtube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
youtube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and say hey you like this you know go
ahead and follow us it's that simple so
tip number ten take on the latest trends
to get more followers so align your
content to cater to trendy topics or
hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here's your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by looking at hashtags so
what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keeping in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
can just do something for fun especially
if you have a lot of followers if you
have a lot of followers and somebody's
going to take part in it so don't be
afraid to run contests just to make it
fun and light it up a little bit so each
tag can bring you a new audience member
who could be a potential follower so
anytime you run a contest people are
going gonna tag their friends to let
them know about that contest so those
friends are gonna come over and likely
engage so that's the beauty of running a
contest or giveaway is chances are
word's gonna spread and it's gonna get
you some new followers so that's the the
end benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with post so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of instagram content
so that mean what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water suppose so to speak and you're
probably gonna get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the genes industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and that kind of blurs your your
personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are gonna start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like socialblade i could tell you how
many followers you lost over time and
how engaged they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so let's take a look at
socialblade as an example here so if i
go over here i'm going to go to
socialblade here i can enter in
basically any account after i register
and i could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on what industry
and the beauty here is i could see and
i'm looking at youtube as an example i
could see you know how my post to
perform well you could do this for
instagram you could do it for facebook
so you can really get an idea of how
your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring it and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're gonna do is you're gonna go
to your app right and then from the app
you could basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're gonna click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions and some
engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the
instagram insights analytics insights
but you can also see additional
information from socialblade so the key
here is when you're looking at your data
you want to look for patterns and post
what posts receive the most amount of
engagement so if you see something
working obviously replicate it you know
you don't want to replicate it
immediately but make note of it and use
it for future content so tip 14 use
instagram ads so instagram ads give you
complete control over advertisements so
how they appear and who sees them so
with instagram ads you can run photos
you can run videos carousels slideshows
stories so we mention this on other
webinars for facebook advertising it's
worth repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel so really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's gonna tell
you you know what your audience size is
your potential reach okay what your
daily results would be so you're gonna
get all that information when you run
your ads on facebook ads manager but
it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting units you need
meaning you know who saw the ad did they
click on it okay you can refine that
target audience you can go back into
facebook ads manager and refine who your
audience is so lots of flexibility here
and advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to measuring the
engagement of your instagram post you're
definitely going to need a social
media tool so you're also going to need
it if you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com
so if i go later here i can see you know
i can use this to upload my images to my
profile so here you can see it's
scheduled throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping you
know we're scheduling based on the times
of the day that people are gonna look at
this so
you know here i could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by a
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature styles to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all this
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example um of
what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so
if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship and you know increase
your followers and you want to be able
to see of that user generated content
that ugc which is performing which is
not performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you could set up your
own unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety and some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on youtube just
like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza's made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it can be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely gonna
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or or youtube the whole idea
is to get users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always put that url in you
know other platforms like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page offline with
print ads and during other relevant
events and then i would even take this
to further is you'll probably see you
know an instagram logo on a web page
along with other social media icons so
you always want to help promote
instagram on your web page as well but
you can do it for offline with print ads
so you can simply just put you know
whatever your your slug is for instagram
whatever your id is whatever you're
using on instagram that's what you can
use don't be afraid to promote it
offline or online today we're going to
talk about how to increase twitter
followers so welcome and let's get
started
so with twitter it's all about tweets
it's actually a verb now uh when you do
something on twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts
so
a lot of tweets going on in the world of
twitter so as of the third quarter in
2018 last year twitter had 326 million
global monthly active users okay so
active meaning every day using the
platform on a daily basis so a lot of
people using twitter it's very easy to
use as you'll find out and what you're
going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so
if you watched our youtube videos and
some of the other videos we had out
there regarding facebook or instagram
you'll know that videos do perform
better twitter is no exception so if you
have a video even if it's done on
youtube or if it's not unpublished on
youtube use it with twitter you're going
to get more engagement so twitter has 75
of its users use the platform for news
okay so people go to twitter to get
their news that's where they go they
don't go to
a regular website content-based website
they get their news via twitter it's
just very easy to digest because it's so
few characters 75
of b2b businesses market on twitter so
not only is it a b2c or business to
consumer platform it's a b2b business to
business platform so a lot of businesses
are on twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a keyword friendly bio okay
a link to your website and a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if i go to twitter here we go to
simply learn twitter account okay their
handle is simply at simply learn okay
and they've customized the header they
use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so
just a you know customized complete
profile goes a long way you don't have
to go overboard with an elaborate design
so to speak but just make it stand out
make it associate with who you are as a
person and a brand those are best
practices in getting that profile up and
running you don't want to use something
bland and generic you know take the
extra step create something unique make
sure your profile is unique you have a
good image okay make sure it's complete
with you know telling people who you are
and what you're all about that's really
the first step on really any social
media platform so
you want to promote your twitter profile
to drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on facebook
if you're already on instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like i said if
you're on facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys i'm on twitter you
know come follow me so you can also use
business cards advertisements marketing
materials events to put that twitter
profile on okay so it doesn't have to be
within the social media sphere it could
be even on your website it can be even
in email so you can basically promote
that profile again you want to make that
profile that handle easy to remember so
totally real person is the profile on
this example we're going to use that
profile every way we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy i can just
simply go to twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retweet and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on twitter so you could just simply i'm
logged in as me and if i want to retweet
something that simply learn did i can
just simply click on the retweet button
and i can add a comment if i want to and
then i'm going to retweet that simple so
now
that tweet is going to show up on my
profile my handle and i could simply
like it if i scroll down here okay top
10 it trends shaping 2019 notice a
simple tweet supported with an image so
i'm just going to like that so i can
even comment on it i can click on the
comment and click a reply here okay and
that's going to show up in this tweet
here just like if i click on this i'll
be able to see what other people have
written and so it's that simple if i
want i can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is i can do everything i need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweets that's what i
started doing when i started on twitter
in 2008 i didn't know what to write
particularly and i didn't know how to
write it particularly well so i looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simplylearn i retweeted one of their
tweets i liked another one of their
tweets and it's probably going to get
their attention somebody at simply learn
is gonna say okay rob sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
twitter account is to really start
retweeting and liking other tweets from
other users so you can find an
appropriate time to post your tweets to
increase exposure retweets and followers
and you want to do this you could do it
within twitter or as i'll mention later
you can do it in a social media platform
like sprout social or hootsuite or later
or buffer and there's plenty of social
media platforms out there for you to
schedule tweets point is you want to be
able to schedule those tweets when it's
the appropriate time so you don't want
to do it in the middle of the evening
because what's going to happen is likely
by the morning other tweets are going to
bury your tweet so you want to be able
to find the appropriate time to post
your tweets so according to a survey
conducted by hubspot the best time to
post is between 12 and 3 p.m and why is
that well most people are usually on
lunch checking their phones yes twitter
has an app and in fact most people use
the app just like on instagram just like
on youtube the app is very popular on
twitter so it's very easy for somebody
to check tweets especially during the
lunch hour and then from five to six pm
that that in between time when when
people are wrapping up work or heading
home okay so weekdays have shown to have
the maximum amount of engagement so
during the week when people are working
highly engaged with whatever they're
doing depending on what industry you're
in they're likely going to
check the twitter and react during those
times okay so that was a a survey
conducted by hubspot but really what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
one of these social media platforms like
a hootsuite or later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when a what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're gonna
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if i go back to twitter you
know twitter is always going to
recommend somebody for me to follow and
normally those are people that are
similar as myself okay so they're not
just going to choose random people
they're going to choose people who are
following people you're following so
there's going to be a connection to some
degree or they could be people who use
similar hashtags tweeting the same
content so you want to go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
twitter is if you follow somebody on
twitter chances are they're gonna follow
you back you know i was once told when i
was using twitter that hey you want to
give somebody about three days to follow
you back so that's always what the rule
i stuck to you know wait about three
days start following people
you can see here 833 people that or
accounts twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over 10
900 followers to simply learn's twitter
account so for me i don't mind having a
nice balance myself i have just as many
followers as i do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what twitter's gonna
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if i
click on find people i know then i can
upload my contacts from outlook or gmail
and they're going to find people who are
already on twitter based on who i'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way i'm gonna follow simply
learn because i wasn't following them
prior so now i just clicked on the
follow button now i am following so now
i'm gonna see simply learns tweets in my
feed so let's take a second to look at a
brand okay so it's time for brand watch
let's have a look at some of the best
tweets of 2018. now remember there are a
lot of active users millions of active
users that's a lot of tweets so what we
did was we scoured twitter from 2018 and
we went ahead and picked out some tweets
that we thought were pretty good and so
the first one is wendy's now i don't
know if any of you have actually eaten
at wendy's i used to eat at wendy's a
while ago i know their frosties are
pretty good so
what they've done is they incorporated
that frosty as part of a giveaway okay
so basically they're saying hey grab
yourself a free frosty with any purchase
in our app so they're encouraging people
to use our app and then they're
following that up by saying hey and then
join us on twitch from two to five
eastern as we unlock all that frosty
goodness so they're promoting something
that's going to happen on a specific
point in time this is of last january
they're encouraging people to use their
app and they're using that frosty as
kind of a carrot if you will okay it's a
catch it's a giveaway so they were able
to you know basically wrap a bunch of
things into one so get encourage people
to take part and i'm sure a lot of
people went ahead and took part of this
but we could definitely see that 206
retweeted this tweet 302 basically
commented on it and over 3 000 liked the
tweet so the tweet was good and it
basically engaged with users who doesn't
like a free giveaway especially free
frosty so that's why this particular
tweet really does some justice for the
target audience their audience they're
they're giving something away to their
audience just by allowing them to you
know use her out okay so this tweet
combines a lot into one and i like it
apparently a lot more people than i did
3 000 plus also like this tweet and so
moving on to how to increase your
followers on twitter you want to mention
other people in your tweets to increase
engagement so what do we mean by that so
let's look at twitter so go back if we
look at simply learn just take a look at
some of their tweets what they're doing
if we scroll down here they have
hashtags so they are mentioning specific
hashtags but you can also mention
handles as well so the hashtag is always
going to start with either the pound
sign but if we scroll down here if you
use the at symbol you're actually
mentioning somebody so in this case
we're mentioning matt bailey so matt
bailey says is matt bailey's handle and
so if you get a shout out to somebody
they're gonna pick up on that and then
they're going to probably follow you
okay who doesn't appreciate getting
recognized for something especially
something as small as a tweet okay
notice i can go ahead and click follow
if i want to follow them out bailly but
it's not a bad idea to add people into
your tweet and you simply do that by
just using the ad symbol and using their
twitter handle it's a good way to get
recognized by that twitter follower it
also increases engagement because it's
adding validity to the tweet and it
definitely catches the attention of the
person mentioned remember if you use
that person's handle they're going to
see that that you mention them okay and
what it's likely going to do is start
some type of twitter relationship okay
they're going to then follow you you're
going to follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is find
and use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on twitter you
need to use hashtags twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag okay and so what
you can do is figure out what hashtags
are trending so here what twitter does
is they trends for you so these are all
specific hashtags that are trending it's
mother's day happy mother hey sunday
morning whatever works for you these are
trends that happen to be moving meaning
a lot of people are using them clicking
on them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what i would also recommend is
using a unique hashtag the rule of thumb
is usually about two hashtags in a tweet
but that's a rule of thumb but rules are
made to be broken do what's best for you
if you want to include more than two
hashtags go for it the only thing i'm
recommending is include a hashtag so
find out which trending you could just
look right in twitter or you could just
create your own unique hashtag it works
both ways but when you have a hashtag in
your tweet and somebody clicks on it
then they're going to go to that
particular handle that hashtag and so
when they look at the hashtag you're
going to see all the tweets with that
hashtag in it so that's the idea behind
hashtags you want to have hashtags okay
so if somebody clicks on a hashtag that
you used then they're likely going to
see your tweet in that hashtags feed
okay so that's how hashtags work you
want to use hashtags okay but you want
to use hashtags that are relevant to
your branded audience that's really the
key so hashtags help your tweets to be
found through twitter search thus
improving your reach and increase the
visibility of your post so that's
another benefit twitter has search
functionality so somebody can simply go
in and start searching on twitter so if
i go back to twitter i can just do a
hashtag and start typing in something
like spanish and i'm gonna get some of
the most popular spanish hashtags or
hashtags with the word spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if i want
to use a hashtag with spanish in it
these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on twitter okay so
if i just click on spanish okay i'm
gonna be able to see all the hashtags
with the word spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of twitter bar none
so some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know i work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if i wanted to be just like
simply learn well i could simply just go
to their twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtags see what kind of
tweets they're implementing and see
who's following them so i can simply
just click on the 10
900 followers that they have and what i
could do is i can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's a good tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from others
in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets gets some sense of what they're
doing and again when i say mimic i mean
whatever what i'm saying is pull best
practices from that twitter account this
will give you an idea what you need to
do to get more followers so it's always
a good form of flattery when you can
mimic what somebody else is doing just
like every other social media platform
following twitter influencers who belong
in your industry is always a good idea
so if you're in the food industry and
there's these star chefs out there
probably not a bad idea to follow those
star chefs you know if you're in the
technology industry well probably not a
bad idea to you know follow bill gates
or elon musk or richard branson or
somebody else and that's a big
influencer has an influence on a lot of
people okay but make sure they're in
your industry that's the key if you can
make sure they're in your industry and
you follow them chances are if they look
at your twitter account and see you're
posting or maybe retweeting some of
their tweets they're likely to follow
you and if they're following you your
tweets are gonna show up on their handle
on their feed and so don't be afraid to
go out and connect and follow those
influencers it's a good way to boost up
your followers so again this will help
you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mind so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their post so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simplylearn so
if i click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that matt bailey was at so it was a
retweet from matt bailey as a matter of
fact but you can see what simply learns
doing is they're including either a
video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than 150 percent engagement okay
videos are six times more likely to be
retweeted so if you have an arsenal
video or even one video don't be afraid
to use it my recommendation is trying to
use images as much as you can in almost
every tweet images go a long way and
again it's going to help improve
engagement meaning more retweets more
followers okay more followers more
eyeballs so it's a snowball effect just
by using images okay so let's take a
look at another brand from 2018 okay
pizza always my good example to use on
these webinars i like pizza here this
just says it all you know they're
talking about art and they're using
pizza in the form of art so they didn't
really have to say much else here this
pretty much says it all and they did get
some retweets to get some to some likes
so sometimes you don't have to say a lot
to make your point sometimes just the
image itself will do the job this was
actually not from 2018 this goes all the
way back to 2016. so still holds true if
you use an image that image is going to
get engagement okay so
on platforms you can promote your tweet
so you can use twitter ads to do that so
you can promote your tweet and what you
do by promoting it is putting it up
above so that most people will be able
to see it okay so see if we can find an
example if i go here i can see this
person is promoting their handle but if
i go down here i can see a promoted
tweet by constant contact so they're
promoting their tweet here so it's not a
bad idea if you have some media budget
to go ahead and either promote your
tweet or advertise on twitter so what
that's going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from constant contact
so if i click on that i'm gonna go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the right audience
and so twitter's no exception so with
twitter you could put yourself in front
of the right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tell your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or trend or account to be
in front of its targeting is based on
either engagement or it's based on
keywords i.e
so really you could tailor who you want
your tweet or your handle to be in front
of and so that's the really the benefit
of twitter if you have a lot of active
users on twitter you can really put
yourself in front of those active users
if they're your relevant audience at a
low cost per click so it's definitely
worth the test so you want to offer
twitter support to your users okay so i
can't stress this enough okay so what
you want to do is when users have
questions about your product they're
more likely to tweet you for support
hence they're likely to follow your
account so don't be afraid to use the
messaging option as well so we go back
to twitter okay chances are somebody
might have a question for you here you
can look at bing ads it's great
connecting with ppc experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of twitter
followers you want to build your twitter
following naturally twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shut down shut down by
twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices and organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories i mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things i do is i'm definitely one
for industry news so if i'm in the
industry of digital marketing if google
did a recent algorithm update i'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it i
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if i blog i'm going to make sure
that blog gets over to twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so i'm in digital
marketing i deal with pay-per-click seo
but am i going to just do pay-per-click
and seo no i know that analytics i know
that you know google tag manager i know
that a b testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so i'm
going to branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing a variety to the type of
content you share so don't just stick to
one thing you know feel free to reach
out a little bit shake things up by
sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so
here you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that insight with you
and so this was interesting when i saw
this so what i did was i simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you wanna look at this particular
study i just went to twitter and i typed
in that hashtag and now i'm going to be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 i teach friends shaping 2019
so i'm just following the twitter handle
that they used so forrester does a lot
of good research a lot of good insights
and so what they've done here that makes
this tweet look so good is they've
actually put an image of the results in
the tweet so they used an image to help
gain engagement or increase engagement
notice they also gave a shout out to
somebody as well as use some good
hashtagging so good tweet this was back
in 2016. but again a good use of the
image with the tweet so you want to
organize tweet chats to interact with
your users and bring in new followers so
you know you basically want to be
organized when you're dealing with with
chat so tweet chats enable you send out
tweets on a particular topic using a
designated hashtag so during a certain
time to interact with your your
followers and other users so you could
do it at a specific time to really get
out a specific topic but you want to be
able to stay organized so that you know
you what you're chatting about is
reaching the wider audience and you're
getting the right following and the
right engagement okay you can also pin
your best updates and tweets to your
profile so you can just use that pin and
what that's going to do is pin it to the
top and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engage with and that's
going to encourage them to share and
probably follow you so and and that's
always what you want to do you always
want to put your best foot forward so
pin your best tweet to your profile so i
mentioned this earlier use tools to
schedule when to publish your tweets so
here are some of the most popular
platforms you know i.e sprout social so
if we take a look at sprout social here
i'm in sprout social i'm connected to my
twitter account i can simply just start
tweeting about something here so you can
see it's gonna let me know how many
characters i have remaining so to 180 to
start out with when i'm done tweeting
notice i can add an emoji
i can upload media i can tag a specific
location okay i can even you know call
out a specific twitter profile now i can
schedule this myself or i can use the
schedule below i can pick and choose a
time to schedule the tweet now again you
want to be able to use the sprout social
whatever social media tool you're using
two
figure out when the best time of day and
the day of the week to actually tweet
when are you getting the best engagement
so ideally that's what you want to do
you want to tweet when you're likely to
get the best engagement when those
eyeballs are actually going to look at
that tweet okay but you also want to
separate out your tweets so they're not
on one on top of another because if you
actually tweet back to back then those
tweets are just gonna get buried so if
you spread them out a little bit then
you're likely to maximize your number of
impressions or eyeballs on that tweet so
if you schedule a tweet multiple tweets
in the same day then post them a few
hours apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you in not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social hootsuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with wendy's is run
contest or giveaways remember randy's
gave away that free frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if i just go to my website here if i
scroll down we actually have your
twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see i just retweeted the simply learn
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what i retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
gonna show up on your website and it's
gonna show that hey you're fresh you're
engaging you keep up to date it's just
going to make it look good and make your
website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but i would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention when this is from playstation
so playstation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on apple tv today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today
you know check out this new feature that
got supported on apple tv so you never
know what's going to happen with a tweet
when you tweet good things are likely
going to happen whether that be somebody
liking it retweeting it or somebody
adding you as a follower something's
good is going to come out of tweeting
twitter is an easy platform to use and
if you take into account all these best
practices you are going to increase your
twitter followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
storytelling when it comes to consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the storytelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of improvement
in the last several years in social
media with more and more brands moving
towards this idea of sort of humanizing
their companies by telling the stories
that come out of the company itself out
of the use of the product or even out of
the consumer stories that you know share
how products benefit their lives or
again just what goes on in that
interaction and that dynamic between the
organization and between the customer
side of things now when it comes to
storytelling there's several different
ways in which this approach offers value
to a business and one of the key ones is
on the emotional side we've talked a lot
in the social sharing dynamic in some of
the other areas of you know the the
spread and the viral concept about how
emotion is one of the most powerful
things that impacts people's
decision-making and engagement with the
brand so when it comes to creating that
emotional connection or leaving people
with some type of emotional response
storytelling is one of the most powerful
ways to impact that it gives you an
opportunity to sway the emotion of
consumers in terms of how they look at
or view or are receptive to your brand
now another thing that storytelling can
really do that adds a lot of value is
the idea of making you credible because
a lot of times the way we tell stories
especially when we're incorporating in
true to life examples or you know
consumer stories there's an implied
credibility that comes through that
storytelling and comes through those
third-party experiences that can help
people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling brings a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories
we are much more capable of recalling
broad ideas and concepts and emotions
when they're communicated via a story so
if we give someone a list of facts a
list of selling points you know a list
of reasons why to do business with you
the ones that touch them emotionally or
that you know problem solve those tend
to stick with them but a lot of the data
gets lost but when we put it in the
format of a story and someone is sharing
what their experience was our brains
literally archive it and categorize it
differently and our recall level goes up
so again along with building trust and
along with creating that that emotional
impact the fact that people are better
able to recall the information that's
communicated to them via that story
helps make it a very powerful marketing
tool now in addition to that it's
important to keep in mind that on
average
people tend to be daydreamers in fact
study after study shows that if our
minds aren't occupied with an important
task if we're not truly focused on
something we tend to drift off and when
we look at that concept of daydreaming
the average human spends literally half
of their waking hours daydreaming we
average 2 000 waking drifts per day with
an average length of about 14 seconds so
you do the math on that 2000 times times
14 seconds that's a pretty good portion
of our day where our brain is drifting
off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drips we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging story we are better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you
now think of storytelling from sort of
the mindset of how we meet and engage
with other people so in general when
we're meeting up with a prospective
friend or a job prospect maybe we're
coming for an interview a service
workers even just a stranger on the
street any conversation that goes past
just hello how are you doing and the
cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information about who another
person is
and in those interpersonal relationships
the types of questions we ask you know
the words we use they're indicative of
the type of relationship we want to
build so clearly if you know if you're
single and you see someone else that you
know you hope might be single that might
be one of the early questions you ask
and then based on whether you know
there's a romantic interest there you're
probably going to ask different
questions than if it's a interview
prospect for a job or if you're meeting
up with a you know co-worker for the
first time the relationship that we're
looking for denotes the type of
information we want and that's one of
the important things for us to keep in
mind when it comes to storytelling is we
also have the ability to tailor our
story to the audience so we can put
those different features up front we can
weave them in in a different way if
we're appealing to
a group of 60 something females that
love to sew versus a group of 20
something millennials that love whiskey
tasting it's a different message that
gets put together with different focuses
and features there's also different
things that we're going to put forward
if we're proposing you know a million
dollar contract versus a 25 impulse buy
that someone can you know click and
order online and have delivered the next
day
now on the business side of this we need
to think about what the story that we
need is because a lot of times we get so
focused in business on getting the
conversion
that we forget that sometimes part of
getting that conversion is creating
those emotions building that credibility
and trust you know helping them have
exposure to what's possible and for a
long time this has been done through
education we might put up videos or
articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind
so a quote that i really love about this
concept that sort of lays the foundation
of why it's so important comes from the
chief content officer over at digitas
and he says the challenge is clear by
now intrusive interruptive self-centered
marketing no longer works the way it
once did and its effectiveness will only
continue to diminish in the social age
because again the way that we share
information back and forth with each
other and the ways that that messages
spread it happens differently in the
social media age than it did before when
it was more advertising focused and
where marketing really was more about
you know pushing the advertise pushing
the message and sort of the don draper
style of you know if you don't like the
conversation change the conversation and
tell people what you want them to hear
because so much marketing is now driven
by consumers through that conversation
we need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone in spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that i want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach
and i love this seth godin quote that
really pairs up with that idea the best
part of show-and-tell has never been the
telling part it's been the showing
letting someone see an experience and
inviting them into that shared
experience and that's one of those
things that makes the social version of
storytelling really more like story
sharing especially if you want to do it
in a way that creates that back and
forth consumer engagement story telling
in its traditional sense is more the
stories that we've put into commercials
and advertising and there's a place for
that there's a place to put that
together in the social realm and it's
very important but the other area that
that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story
but we can focus in on a couple key
areas as a starting point to build from
one of the first ones is the idea
of whether or not you have a founder's
story now for a lot of brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was steve jobs and the role
he played at apple or walt disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire disney complex
or loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now great
example of this is spanx the founder
sarah blakely has really embraced the
story both of how she came up with the
idea which was basically she was trying
to fit into a pair of cream pants for a
party and they didn't fit quite right
and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to neiman marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room
and she went in and she put on a pair of
white pants and came out and said you
know here's what i look like without
them and went back in and put her pair
of spanx on under the white pants and
came back out and said now here's what
happens when i'm wearing these and the
buyer from neiman marcus ended up
placing a huge order and it was the
first major sale that she got that put
her in place somewhere so those stories
and sort of the yeah this is how it
happened you know this is literally what
a difference it makes
that becomes part of the brand and sort
of sarah blakely's journey as an
entrepreneur and you know moving her way
up into the you know the forbes list
of uh you know highest earning females
in the united states
all of that plays a huge role in how
they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain wendy's in
the us and canada where dave thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know he passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that a working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working-class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was ceo to see him
show up in a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays into the narrative of wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there
post cereal paired up with burns group
and use real factory workers to create a
round of honey bunches of oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
i get out of work and i go to the store
and somebody's
smelling around
i smell cookies i said oh no you just
smell me i just got out of work that's
honey bunches old that's all i said
don't eat me now
[Music]
now there's short
simple easy stories there's nothing
complex to them they more just make you
smile and laugh but they're the types of
stories that come from listening to the
people who work at your company from
thinking about how your company and
their experience impacts the world
around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem
now this isn't about the reasons you
think you're great or the reason you
think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or
on the b2b side of things you know that
the buying agent is looking at that
they're trying to fix
now a great example of this is airbnb or
you could look at uber or lyft on a
similar vein
allowing people to experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when i
travel for business pretty much any
place i go i always book via airbnb
because you know if i can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and i
it just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes
and even on the side of trying to
recruit people to put their properties
it becomes about the freedom and the
lifestyle that's enabled and there's
tons of examples on youtube of people
sharing how you know leasing out that
you know their vacation property the
rest of the year when they're not there
you know pays for the vacation property
and more or you know the people who now
travel full-time because they're able to
lease out you know their apartment or
their home or something else on airbnb
the story side comes from the problems
that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is dollar shave club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and
you know it shows up right at your house
and you don't ever have to think about
it anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example
as a founder of my own club i'd love to
know how does yours work dollar shave
club presents what the fact it's simple
you choose from one of our three great
razors we'll give you a free reusable
handle and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks that means you get to shave with
the fresh blood any time you want which
feels amazing
will i be locked into a contract
no we wouldn't lock you into anything
that's a relief how long for delivery
i've got a conjugal visit next week
well what if i don't have to shave that
often
no problem after you sign up you can
choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
i like that
what's this i hear about dollar shave
club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like dr cover
shave butter boogie's hair gel and
big cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up from dollar shave club so join the
club today
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it linkedin facebook or
instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that burger king video
advertising their new whopper
or about a marketing tool that can help
you visualize your team's workload
better than any other in the market
right now
now these are just some of the many ways
that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data
and running social media advertisements
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are facebook
instagram twitter linkedin and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness
now with the help of interactions with
people on social media brands are able
to build up their reputation as a
business
and with each interaction each post each
share the brand is exposed to a larger
network of potential customers who might
be interested in the products or
services offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website
outside your usual customer base
next it improves your brand's search
engine rankings
now although this isn't a direct
correlation
social media marketing does have a part
to play when it comes to helping your
page rank higher up in search engine
rankings now if you start posting high
quality content
people will start liking and sharing it
this will in turn bring it to the
attention of influencers within the
industry who will be willing to write
about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting your brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compassion
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
now compared to other forms of digital
marketing
social media marketing offers some of
the most flexible and relatively low
cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures
now if you do get into paid advertising
a good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your authority
you can have your followers look up to
you now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind
the goal of your marketing strategy will
be the driving force behind every
decision that you make
now this is exactly why setting up goals
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative
for example you need to have thousand
conversions by the end of the quarter or
5000 followers on instagram by the end
of the month and so on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives wait for
each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and time
based
now let's go to number four
like i mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the north star metric
now what is the not star metric
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this north star metric will also give
your team clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
not stars
there's increased engagement greater
conversion rates more leads generated
app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for
now there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them
the age demographics of your audience by
conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments on blogs
and social media taking up their
feedbacks or suggestions into
consideration and acting on them
and so on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we taken our personal example
hither simply learn now simply learns
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the baiju's app
has high school students as users
now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now while selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform
who you'll reach with this platform
what content would work best on the
platform and is there any content that
was unique to that platform for example
youtube and then there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones there's
linkedin facebook instagram and
pinterest
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms
now linkedin is a professional network
that's best suited for b2b audiences
now for facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
facebook
then we have instagram
visual content works best on instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have pinterest pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
a social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience
it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media
first off we have competitions
now i'm sure all of you have seen posts
like tag a friend who does this or
comment or like to win something and
stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience now they can be used to
encourage your followers to share your
content it could be also for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media
then we have polls or service
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams
now although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
now these help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and so
much more to offer
live stream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business
humanizes your brand and by extension
helps increase customer loyalty and
trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process
you can plan create and schedule posts
on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer hootsuite bus
sumo if triple t and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of posts
now for number six
visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information in the simplest
of forms
visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it
this can help your audience stay
interested and engaged grab the
attention of potential clients and so
much more
but it also has some other advantages
it helps you build a bond with your
audience
visual storytelling connects with your
audience methods like live streaming
help humanize your brand and help grow
customer loyalty and trust
it helps the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature
and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
now here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and ai in five
minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our channel
and now you know why
visual storytelling
if you guys are interested in watching
these videos you can check them out on
our channel home page we also have
similar videos about blockchain devops
and six sigma
now
back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach
and improve your brand's visibility
its pay-per-click model ensures cost
effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investment it also
helps improve targeting by letting you
control who sees your ad you get to
choose from a number of different
factors like interests hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic user demographics like age
location gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
refine the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content
disregarding it in the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have an uphill battle to deal with
better funded organizations
next we have number eight newsjacking
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness
news jacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand
it also helps shine a spotlight on your
products it also helps you show off that
you are up to date with current events
in the industry and that your product is
relevant
by extension it also improves engagement
and website traffic
now for number 9
a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media
now since audiences would react
differently depending on the content a b
testing helps determine which of the
variants your audience engaged with the
most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
next up number 10
community and influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
now actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience it
helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in youtube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influences
we have marcus brownlee unbox therapy mr
who's the boss and lioness tech tips
each of them with more than 4 million
subscribers
and finally we're at number 11
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on twitter you could look
out for impressions
clicks and impressions and interactions
on linkedin
likes comments and mentions on instagram
and engagement and impressions on
pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are sprout social buffer
hootsuite google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website sign ups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one
remarket your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon
and changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content
this is why you need to focus on
google's featured snippet this position
also known as position zero enhances and
draws user attention on the search
engine's result page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel
see how he himself is the brand and if
you've gone through his content you know
it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you're
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five back up your
arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content this will
also help your content have a greater
chance of being found indexed and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you back up your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create value-built
content and fix pain points faced by
your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 of them felt content marketing
was really important to their digital
marketing campaigns and more than 25
percent of their budgets are used for
visual advertising content like images
infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content instagram
and pinterest for visual content twitter
for smaller snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect
demographics of your target audience
based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it signs that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature
that's part of that product that you
offer then that's the segment you're
going to be writing about so you need to
collect your data on your audience ahead
of time then you're going to segment
that audience okay so you're not going
to write content for everyone because
the shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone okay the shoe has to fit for
specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest i mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
have purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be
an age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information
using google analytics
just got to go in the analytics under
audience under demographics you're going
to see age and br it's age is broken out
by age range and they're going to see
gender so you're going to see a
breakdown of gender and use that to your
advantage so if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly you know how many
fans you have broken out by men versus
women and then you can see again same
thing as google analytics you could see
an age range breakout you could use
twitter analytics i mean twitter has
shared some really good insights into
education level so you know if you're
dealing with you know highly
sophisticated people who have master's
degrees or even higher or let's just say
even on linkedin you know that a
majority of the people you're trying to
target are c-level meaning ceos
or cfos or cmos you know chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high-range managers or even vps so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now i know this sounds like a
given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's going to
result in a lot of things that are going
to benefit you you know one you're gonna
come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's gonna help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are gonna share
that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you've got good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether it's a video or a blog post or
or infographic you know people are going
to become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interest in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points change so these are all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points and then just don't put words on
a web page you know to break up that
content with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you don't withhold it have
them come back and read a secondary blog
post or secondary piece that supports
the original now we want to move from
high quality content to running a b test
baby test so important why because with
a b split testing you can increase your
conversion rates okay so
four elements to test in your content
marketing strategy so if you have
content say a blog and you're testing
that blog you know test out the images
test out the forms do you have a long
form or short form you know test out the
content length you can have a variation
that is a lot shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
your call to actions do matter you know
do you want to use a softer call to
action a softer tone or do you want to
use something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the
closer to purchasing and through that
funnel so a b testing to me is something
that should be naturally done with
google optimize it's free so with images
you know you could test a lot of
different variations of images anything
from people
to
you know outlandish imagery to just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's gonna stay a little bit
longer on the page so
you know create a variation it's gonna
play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you can push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know europe or the west
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitor's top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search
sem rush or moz or something like that
that's going to allow you to get some
good insight on competitor information
so keep in mind there are seo platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these seo
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
let's say official route with an e-book
or case study something that
a user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download
something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an ebook now if you're into
talking like i am then you could
certainly do a podcast and podcasts are
always popular depending on the topic so
you got to be aware of the topic now
videos are always always a good option
you got the likes of video and video and
youtube and some other you know video
platforms out there that allow you the
ability to get found very quickly
especially with the likes of youtube you
know people use youtube before they go
on to purchasing a product so think
about that so if you're trying to get
somebody if you're trying to sway an
audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points try
using an infographic to convey those
points visually now again with blog
posts it should have valuable content
that can be shared by your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so and it
shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded in and you
solving that customer's problem so the
case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is the podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce manage
publish and measure results all in one
place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share
you know hotspot could be the way to go
okay there are lots of available options
out there so moving on number seven
target your audience using emails okay
so what are we talking about well we all
know what emails are emails help us to
communicate directly with our target
audience and convert them to leads so
email is a good way to follow up with
your audience so if you've done a
podcast follow up with an email you know
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or
if you create a podcast about some data
that you talked about in that podcast
follow up that with with them via email
with an infographic perhaps okay built
into the email okay there's lots of ways
that all these formats can complement
themselves via email okay you could
certainly take a blog post and package
it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your target audience are
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or
what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice content via
email okay just make sure you know your
target audience is there's lots of
things you can do in email again you can
complement lots of different formats
within email as i mentioned before with
a podcast or a blog post so keep all
that in mind email's a good way to
communicate with your audience okay the
last point we want to make here is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
buzzfeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably won't exist without led
zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who led zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to led zeppelin okay so
you can see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
to say the headline or led zeppelin per
se but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 more likely to look at a native ad
than add a banner and so that native ad
in this case we're talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music just music in general might
get enough to get peak people's interest
okay so if you're going to create
content you know align that content with
something that's you know naturally
going to fit and that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that they're associated with so
finally after all that's said and done
when all you've done is create good
content follow up via emails targeting
your audience and associating that
content with you know content natively
then you can always measure your content
performance so
my favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going to facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content's performing and you want
to do that because
you want to be able to see what's
performing what's not performing the key
here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available you
know if you're in it for search okay how
much traffic getting from search where
are you ranking so there are a lot of
things you need to think about so think
about the content that you're producing
and think about how you want to be able
to measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here
so
what you could do is create an editorial
calendar in fact i would highly suggest
you create an editorial calendar in
order to keep track of all the content
you've done over a period of time are
you making your content worth reading
that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content
okay you always want to you know make
sure you're reusing or using or adding
to the content that you've created guest
post on influential blogger websites you
want to add statistics numbers and
quotes to your content make it engaging
make it look like you've done your
homework you could share all your
content not just on social media but you
know platforms like slideshare now you
can share it on all social media
platforms i'd highly recommend it and
again you can even repurpose it as a
blog post so if it's a podcast then you
know you can recite that podcast in the
form of a blog okay so get some
testimonials that support some of your
content again create a podcast you can
send out an email with a survey or
trying to solicit some testimonials or
if you post something on facebook you
know leverage the feedback you get from
facebook in the form of a testimonial
okay and then you want to promote your
blog post for maximum success and a lot
of that means seo so make sure you do
your due diligence and get the right
keywords in that blog post okay so you
can create personas for different user
audiences okay so remember it's all
about tone okay so if you're going to
create a blog post make sure your tone
is aligned with that right audience
whether that be young middle aged or
older are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadatas title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even alt tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up in search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search okay
so you want to create a detailed summary
and title and again that goes along with
the title tag and meta description and
then you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and comment on
your blog so don't be afraid like i'm
gonna do right now in this video is if
i'm missing anything from this checklist
feel free to comment hey i've written my
fair share content but i could be
talking to an audience that is just as
qualified as i am and they may have some
tips so feel free to comment underneath
this video now don't be afraid to ask
just like i just did people are always
willing to provide constructive feedback
so don't be afraid to ask for it and
make it easy so to me every blog post
needs to have some form of a comment box
because blog posts are out there to
solicit engagement now let's recap
everything we talked about because we'd
certainly covered a lot and there's a
lot to cover when it comes to content
marketing so one know your audience
again you can lean on google analytics
you know demographic data whether it be
age or gender you could do the same with
facebook and twitter and linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when i mean high quality content
just brainstorm some topics has it
already been written to death about or
is this unique you know don't write
something your competitors are writing
okay don't copy what your competitors
have written organize your content
support it with good imagery all of
these are tips to creating high quality
content okay when you create that
content think about running some a b
test you know run some variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like sem rush and moz all you got to do
is plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about where a
particular competitor ranks for keyword
or how many backlinks and what websites
are linking to them so all that's
available in these seo platforms okay so
you want to choose a suitable content
format we listed a few from ebooks to
case studies to podcasts to infographics
to blog posts to videos it's up to you
what you think is best for your audience
just keep in mind you need to be able to
measure it and so that's the important
thing if it doesn't work the first time
out then you might want to consider
changing out the content format choose a
content management system you know
plenty out there wordpress is a good one
if you're going to be a blogger okay
blogging allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so
you know if you created a video
you know put that video in the form of
an email and send it out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and pair it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it
line your kpis so if it's an e-book or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people are actually
downloading them okay if it's a video
how many people like the video how many
people are commenting how many people
are sharing the video how many people
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from wordpress to youtube to
reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing you're doing
some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends and an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics
and you notice your traffic's very low
okay well you're scratching your head
because you've done all this work with
your website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing designing
the website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything or any planning or
any strategy around bringing users to
your website so the two go hand in hand
you just can't build a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're going to earn a percentage of
that click okay what that click is worth
so having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad then it's going to be more
visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so that's paid advertising
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms i mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook you can also advertise on
instagram and or instagram so it doesn't
have to be and facebook and instagram it
could be facebook or instagram you also
have linkedin as a platform linkedin is
great for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so
linkedin is great if you're into b2b
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest post blogging so
most of you already know what blogging
is all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's gonna build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for service
because it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging is a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
an effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because google
is going to recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media following because you
can then promote that on social media
that you're guest blogging okay again
you can improve your online authority
okay because when you're guest blogging
and you have recognition on that guest
blog if it's a popular blog then it's
not going to help your domain and page
authority for seo and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms and that could in turn drive
traffic to your website obviously just
like guest blogging it's going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there nobody knows who your brand is
and they know who they thought leaders
are and they say you're interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people and so it's
going to increase your reach another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
contents all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and then identify people who
identify with your brand and messaging
and talking to them as if they're part
of your own community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies i.e advertising i.e
post on social okay it can also provide
pr opportunities so it's a chance for
you to you know put out press releases
based on the community that you built so
any brand regardless of who it is should
be able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell
what your cause is what your mission
statement is what your services they
identify with you so leverage them and
reciprocate identify them talk to them
separately
give them the
what they deserve the respect and
loyalty that they deserve as well
because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do
to drive traffic is be active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se could be other sites like reddit or
cora or media sites that have a lot of
content that are broken out by industry
that allow you to engage in conversation
allow you to either upvote or share or
respond okay so be active because when
you're active people are gonna see that
hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of engagement so the the
amount of traffic you drive from organic
search to your website is only going to
improve engagement okay so
you can also provide an improved user
experience and what do we mean by that
well if you're getting lots of traffic
from organic search you have a really
good opportunity to do a b testing and
when you do a b testing you can improve
user experience meaning you're showing
one variation against the other from
people coming from organic search and so
this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're going to
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so again you have
a chance to really be visible for what
people are looking for and so that's the
beauty of search engine optimization you
have a really good opportunity here to
meet people halfway to drive quality
traffic to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generating
engagement and along with seo we want to
be able to build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on-page
and off page and so
off-page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
backlinking because it's an off page
strategy why is it an off page seo
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust this site so
by google trusting your site it's going
to improve your organic ranking and with
the organic rankings being approved
meaning it's going to mean faster
indexing so what does that mean so you
want to be indexed by the search engines
and so the quicker google can find your
pages even if it's on somebody else's
site then that means they're going to
follow that link go to that page on your
site and take that page back to their
servers to be indexed okay so the
quicker you can get index the quicker
you get found and then it helps with
referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credit from an seo perspective
from an internal linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has really good relevance in
the eyes of google then the other page
is probably going to benefit from that
the other reason you want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply the rate at which people land on
a page and then leave so if i have a
hundred people land on my home page and
only one person went to another page and
the other 99 left the site then that's a
99 bounce rate so by putting internal
links in place you're helping people
move from one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older post we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and we'll meet by link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so they're usually three or longer
keywords in a phrase okay so long tail
keywords really nowadays account for
most web searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red
nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for red shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a two
pronged approach on page and off page we
talked about off page with internal
linking and backlinks on page is all
about making sure those keywords you
choose are integrated in with the page
you want to be found for and so if
you're using a long tail keyword it's
just easy to work that keyword in so it
enables easier on-page optimization okay
let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so let's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it can be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the
email provider you're using really is a
flat fee so it just really depends on
how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely majority of the people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so
the other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email are the ones who
sign up for the email so they're almost
expecting your email so when they get
your email again as long as you're not
sending an email on a daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly it's not going to be as
intrusive okay and then it also helps
build credibility increased visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email you're
going to put content in that email
that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you could put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
facebook community you could do a
facebook live event or you could do a
youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you could do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or or roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get bail trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video 2 is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share that particular video which is
going to bode well for your brand and
traffic okay so video if somebody likes
a video it's very easy to share video
especially from a mobile phone so
youtube just makes it so easy to share
or like or subscribe to a channel it
just it becomes that much easier things
can go viral and chances of them going
viral video are gonna be greater okay so
other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
reddit people are either going to upvote
it or downvote it so the more upvotes
you get or thumbs up or likes or people
who encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a a social post
or blog post make sure the content's
unique professional and interesting and
then if you do say put something on
medium or you do put something on cora
and it is professional and interesting
and thought-provoking then people are
going to react to it and then that again
could lead to traffic but even if it
doesn't lead to traffic it helps build
brand awareness so if you have content
just like videos leverage it put the
content out there and when you put
content out there it's only gonna
especially if it's good content put it's
gonna put you in a good light so don't
be afraid to share your content on the
likes of reddit or medium or core or
some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic seo brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics so i have to do is
just go to google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and while uh they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming to your website and not
only are they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or are they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or are they coming from
organic search it is so google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our seo efforts
and then with google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by page by language
by city by region i mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information in analytics if that's your
target audience then you could see how
they're performing okay so and there are
a lot of benefits to google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data is you want to be able to
fine-tune your website so take advantage
of the data that google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the leads she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers okay so customers
sign up but they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do so how's she gonna
solve the problem of converting the lead
she gets into paying customers well look
no further than email market so you can
boost your sales funnel with the help of
email marketing so email marketing leads
to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your tail i made is a very efficient way
to generate a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening
what's in it for you
why are you going to invest your time
and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because we're going to talk
about everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're going to talk about how to set up
email marketing we're going to discuss
all the benefits of email marketing
we're going to get into a b testing
we're going to get into the automation
of emails the types of emails how to
engage new users and we're going to give
you a demo so there's a lot going on in
this webinar like i said buckle up and
let's get started and talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our products we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our products okay so that's what email
is going to do we're going to
communicate with them via email and
we're going to bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so we're running a
cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer smooths hydrates and
contains spf 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
talk about purchase the next step in the
life cycle well purchase well with
purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discount's always tend
to work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're gonna offer them a discount they
can't refuse okay so you know it could
beat for a specific date okay it could
be you know something that's going to
get them excited to buy the product 20
off of moisturizers pretty good deal and
especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in our
inventory so what do we do we're going
to send an email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're going to give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers key is
the offers exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite nonprofit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that they help they help the
environment they help the needy okay
they care and so we can go ahead and
provide a call to action for these
customers that are loyal to our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word on you know
what we're trying to accomplish for our
nonprofit or if anything just get them
to promote it maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be you know just sharing
with friends it can be that extra
incentive of giving them a discount if
they do share with friends and their
friends buy okay so this is the customer
life cycle and examples of different
emails that you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about the benefits of email
marketing so what are some of the
benefits well we've already mentioned to
linda that it's cost effective it's time
saving real time marketing less
intrusive builds credibility increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track roi these are all
the benefits for email marketing and
we're gonna go talk about some of these
now so basically when we talk about cost
effective you know some email marketing
platforms charge based on the number of
users who you send the email to time
saving well you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
when we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs at the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw i can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have chuck here chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing john walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right chuck
responded hey i'm just worried that i
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product i mean i've done
seo i've done paid search i've done
email i've done social man nothing's
working i gotta come up with something
new asap well john responds hey don't
worry i think i've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
john's just taking over now and he's
gonna let chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question john answers for chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if i'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me i'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
john's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away john so
john says first we have the merchant aka
the brand the seller the creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea this
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups to large multinational
companies international companies
non-profits for-profits individuals
independent contractors freelancers a
group of people who have a passion for
something okay it could be anybody
there's no limit the affiliate aka the
publisher so the affiliate is basically
that third-party website or entity which
promotes the merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchant's product's value so this
affiliate going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to
you know sales you know if i'm just
trying to get you know build my email
list then hey i can incentivize that
affiliate to push email signups if i'm
got this big you know offline you know
promotion that i'm doing at this
particular mall and i want to get people
there well i can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that merchant who has
this brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially drive registrations sales
signups etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
affiliates it allows merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate network merchants can
use tools for tracking and reporting and
processing payments for affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
john so the consumer
is the final and most important
component without customers to buy
products the merchant would not have any
revenue and the affiliate would not get
any commission so we need customers so
john what is the process of affiliate
marketing well john says let's have a
look at the process so it's affiliate
marketing time so we're going to use a
tool or platform like commission
junction commission junction is a
popular
you know platform that
affiliate network platform that brings
merchants and affiliates together so the
merchants can use those affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at uh commission junction as a good
digital marketing tool
for affiliate marketing so we're going
to use commission junction as an example
here remember in affiliate marketing
it's an ecosystem between
publishers
and merchants so remember merchants are
selling products publishers are selling
those merchant products on their site
and so commission junction is the
middleman so to speak okay so commission
junction just known as cj now is the
middle person they're introducing the
publisher and the merchant and so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
it's similar to yours okay so we go into
cj.com we're going to log in and here
you can see a publisher's link so we're
going to click on the publishers link
and remember when you sign up publishers
you have to have program terms and so if
we click on publishers program terms
we're going to be able to see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publishers performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole the idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
months to see who's earning the most per
click in terms of publishers now you can
select under publishers groups now you
can group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get
publishers and you want to start
building your base of publishers because
the more publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have publishers who
are promoting your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers now when
you're in cj and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publishers so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling cj is going to try and
put you in front of
some good publishers and so here we
could see if we click on recruit we're
going to get a list of publishers and
this search results list of publishers
that we can recruit into our network are
all listed here and you can actually see
what's interesting you can see the name
of the publisher and you can see the url
and then you can actually see
if they're a good performer or not so
you could actually see
their history as a publisher just by
looking at their network earnings and
then also looking at their seven day
earnings per click or three month
earnings per click and so if a publisher
has a very high earnings per click epc
then they're probably a good publisher
somebody you're probably going to be
interested in so if i see a publisher
with you know three month earnings per
click of 105
then that means hey if that's my
publisher i'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me i want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these publishers and so i can just click
on any one of these publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in cj so
here i can see the particular url the
company some other urls that they have
associated with them in cj i can see the
category that they're in again i can see
the seven three month epc here you can
see description okay you can see some
other promotional methods that they'd
use when promoting products
and you get some permanent performance
from this particular publisher just by
pulling down the pull down menu here i'm
going to look at this year and see what
the performance
and why i'm waiting for that to load i
could see hey they're also in other
countries as well so i can get a good
snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
publishers seeing what their performance
is over a period of time and potentially
you know recruiting that publisher to be
part of my network because if they're
part of my network then hey if they're
selling products if i'm selling products
and i want my product on their site and
they're doing a good job of selling
other products then i want them to be
you know part of my ecosystem part of my
network now remember cj's doing the
introducing here they're introducing you
to recruits so
you want to be able to again take a look
at the site does do any of the sites
that a particular publisher has
interest you you know again we can just
click on it go to the specific site take
a good look hey virgin atlantic okay do
we want them selling our product maybe
maybe not um so you want to take a look
at the website make sure it's not spammy
make sure it aligns with your business
goals it makes your aligns with your
product your target audience remember a
lot of things you want to make sure
the website aligns with because they're
representing your brand okay very
important here very important and so
that's what you want to be able to do
and you could do all that just by
looking at the publisher detail in cj
and then again take a look at earnings
per click if they're selling products
for other merchants and they're doing a
good job maybe you want them selling
your product as well okay so you can
also you know sort by country
you can also do network earnings and you
can really filter here so we want you
know choose high network earners in a
particular country a particular state
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to align
with your geography or you know
definitely you want to align with
somebody who's a high network owner now
when you get all your publishers set up
you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners um you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the publishers with you know the
information they need now
as a best practice remember you can get
on the phone with these publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the cj platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so
if i click on links here
and manage i'll be able to see
everything that i have available for my
publishers to use okay and then you can
actually look at
banners that have actually produced for
you in terms of epc
or you know if it's a specific promotion
okay you could set that up here so you
could be able to see it here you can see
all the banners you can see some text
links in here so all the you know
advertising that you want these
publishers to have is going to be
situated under links and so you can see
what the active ones are you can look at
archived you can look at again text
links content links or banners and as a
best practice if i click on a banner as
a best practice ideally what you want to
do is use utm tracking okay so you want
to have some type of tracking in place
however
cj does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times a banner has been clicked and
how many times a banner's been seen okay
they'll also tell you more importantly
not only was that banner click but did
it generate a sale and so here i can see
that i have three publishers using this
particular banner i can see over this
period of time 412 impressions meaning
412 people viewed the banner and i
received one click on it so you can get
some in-depth detail about your
different marketing materials and how
they're performing okay you can also see
what publishers are using them okay so
the key here is
you want to be able to communicate with
your publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up a
unique banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what i would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
got a 160 by 600 you got a 300 by 250
okay so you want to have different
banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text um ads as well okay you want
to be able to give
your publishers some options in terms of
what to use on their websites so that's
the whole idea because a publisher may
not have space on the home page they may
only have enough space for you know a
text ad or a 300 by 250. so you want to
be able to mix it up and then also mix
up the messaging as well so you can have
the same 300 250 banner but you can have
different messaging just like you see
here 300 by 250. got this messaging here
and we got a different set of messaging
with the same banner size so the more
options you present for yourself the
more of an opportunity you have for the
publisher to use that messaging that
banner that text ad on their website and
then that gives you a better opportunity
to get the click get the conversion that
you seek out so
that is
links so you want to be able to continue
to push out different banners and text
ads now cj also has a great feature in
here if you're selling a lot of products
you have a large inventory of products
you could actually upload a product feed
to cj so you can see in this example we
don't but if you did let's just say you
have a hundred products that you want to
sell you can go ahead and upload that
fee to cj and then the publisher will be
able to use that entirety in its of the
feed or pick and choose different
products to use and sell so let's jump
over to reports and cj you have reports
so this is
really the bulk of where you want to be
spending your time because you want to
be able to
you know not only recruit those
publishers but after you recruit them
you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving or are
publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
product so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see
over a period of time you know are we
selling our product and here you can see
over the last 30 days you could see how
much commission was paid out remember cj
gets a fee they're the broker okay so
that's part of the program terms okay so
it's based on program terms is selling
okay what program term are they
associated with cj gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many impressions so i
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now i can go into detail
if i click on transaction here from the
pull down menu i can look at a specific
order i can choose a specific publisher
or website and i can get details about
that specific order publisher website
etc just be look by choosing transaction
so i can get really granular about the
data i see for a specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now you can also click on
promo codes and if you're running any
promo codes for your publishers you'll
be able to see
how many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the set total sale amount
over the last 30 days so building a
network is all about recruiting the
right publishers giving them the
materials they need measuring the
performance of the publishers and then
communicating it's just so key so cj has
a nice message center built in so you
can actually you know look at the
messages you're getting from your
publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so
communicate
seamlessly and efficiently right in cj
here so i just clicked on mail and we
can see the messages we have so you can
also click on email campaigns and if you
have any email campaigns that you want
to run you can look at them right here
in cj so cj offers up some email
campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our network
so
here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people we're
targeting and opens deliveries etc so if
you want to run an email campaign write
in
it's available to you as part of the
platform so if we move over from mail to
placements we have an opportunity to
place some promotional material on a
publisher's website and so here we could
see a breakdown of different publishers
who basically will offer up some
promotional material that we can
leverage okay so here you got this
particular promotional placement it's a
one month placement and review page with
your ad so we can actually you know take
advantage of what publishers are
offering up on their own website so the
whole idea here is if it's in a prime
position on their website then we can
take advantage of that so then what we
want to be able to do is if we like what
they're offering up you can see hey this
particular publisher saying hey i have a
creative the placement is a home page
banner or full page review provide an
email with a copy of the ad that you'd
like to be displayed and we're going to
email this person here so if we want to
take advantage of a specific promotional
placement on a publisher's website then
we can do that just by clicking on
placements and we'll be able to see
who's offering up what notice there's a
fee involved so it just gives you an
opportunity to
reward a publisher that's performing
well for you and if they turn around and
offer you a better placement for a
little bit more money it might be worth
it so the whole idea is to take
advantage of placements because if your
product is in place properly then
nobody's gonna see it if nobody sees it
then you know they're not gonna click on
it and then you're not gonna get sales
so that's the whole idea here
is take advantage of what publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so cj also has a
pay-per-call
click uh model as well pay model so
basically
your pay per performance is based on
calls so
basically the whole point here is a cj
points out you want to promote
more high ticket and consultative
products and services you want to expand
your reach and you want to get more
qualified sales then you can offer up a
pay per call and the beauty here is cj
tracks the calls so
you will be able to see
the actual phone number and calls so
instead of offering up say you know
banner with a click you can offer up you
know promotional number and have cj
track the calls from the publisher and
that just opens up another opportunity
for you to give your publishers an
option to have people call if they call
then great you know it's another way for
somebody to get in touch and purchase
the product so the pay-per-call method
is available under cj as well so if we
want to get more insights about how our
program is performing we just click on
the insights cj's going to take us to
this overview this dashboard if you will
with some really good data based on a
time frame okay so we're comparing july
through
of july of 19 through july of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks average order
value so there's kind of an overview
dashboard if you will about
how our overall program is performing
there are other similar tools and
resources to include you know max bounty
trade doubler amazon associates there's
plenty of networks out there you want to
find a network where you're gonna have
affiliates that are gonna be passionate
and gonna be relevant and have the
prospective audience that you need to
sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there
and with that we have come to the end of
this digital marketing full course for
2021 i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will help you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you